hi
everyone welcome to this live discussion
brought to you by the world Science
Festival I'm Brian Green I am coming to
you live from my office in the physics
department at Columbia University the
center for theoretical physics and our
discussion today will be with Steph
Wolfram a name that many of you are
quite familiar with from so many
contributions from Mathematica with
has had such a profound influence on the
kinds of science that we are able to
undertake well from alpha the Wolfram
language of course Stephen is a
physicist at heart that's where his
initial training began and our
conversation will focus on some of the
work that he's been doing recently in
trying to give us a perhaps different
way of thinking about the fundamental
laws and before I brings even on I just
want to quickly say look you know those
of you who have followed physics and
science more generally perhaps through
World Science Festival events or books
your own studying look you know that our
goal which really was articulated
perhaps most succinctly by Albert
Einstein is you know trying to figure
out the fundamental laws of the universe
as Einstein said did God have any choice
in the creation of the universe and he
wasn't talking about God in any
conventional sense what Einstein meant
was is there any freedom in the way the
laws of the universe are constructed in
the form that they take or is there some
principle that we're still struggling to
find that would lead us ineluctably
inevitably to a unique description of
physical reality and that's an important
question because look we have developed
over the course of the 20th century the
21st century
general relativity quantum mechanics
Quantum field Theory String Theory far
more speculative of course but I can't
help but throw it into the mix and as we
go ever deeper toward grasping the
fundamental laws of fundamental
mathematical equations in the way that
we typically frame those laws there are
two questions that come to the four
number one have we got the fundamental
laws of course that's vital and we all
agree that that's an ongoing search an
ongoing process no one would say that
today's laws are the laws but even if
sometime in the future we do have those
fundamental laws a key question will be
why those laws and not some other laws
and if we can show that there's a unique
set of laws that meets some very basic
set of Criterion that would certainly
help answer that question or perhaps
we'll be forced to go the other
direction and say well it's not why this
law instead of that law perhaps all
possible laws in some sense are out
there and we as particular observers of
the world only have access to or only
are aware of a certain slice of reality
that's well described by the particular
laws that we have developed that's a
possible direction that this all will go
and Stephen wlfr has been developing
ideas which perhaps is fair to say
intertwine and thread through all of
those interesting scientific and
philosophical ideas and our goal today
will be to tease out exactly where Steph
wilf's program is at the moment and
where it might be heading so with that
let me bring in Stephen Wolfram hey St
how you doing just fine great to see you
nice to see you too and where are you at
the moment physically Concord
Massachusetts ah are you home yeah ah
excellent um so I've been a work from
home guy for for your life years yeah
right long before it was fashionable you
know speaking of that I just do have a a
quick question completely irrelevant for
our conversation but somebody asked me
the other day and I did not know the
answer to it across all of your
endeavors
wolf from research Mathematica and how
how many people work with you I mean
what's your grand total employee base
yeah it's about 800 people a fairly
small operation yeah and it's it's uh my
my basic principle has been automate as
much as possible so we've been kind of
over the years you know what we can do
with with just 800 people is uh uh you
know lots of Leverage from lots of
automation and it's uh you know I I
built the tools we've uh been developing
for so long partly because I wanted to
use them myself and turns out you know
I've I've managed to alternate between
doing basic science and Building
Technology about five times in my life
so far and it's pretty neat because you
know you you build a bunch of science
you see what tools can be built you
build the tools then that lets you build
another level of Science and example the
things things I've been doing recently
in physics they are the result of
multiple rounds of this kind of science
technology iteration so to speak would
it be fair to say when it comes to early
on in your career and again maybe I'm
not framing it in the way that you would
so please feel free to correct but would
you say that your goal at some point was
to drill down in computation and find
the
fundamental ingredients that underly all
comp computation in some Universal
manner that would allow you to create a
system like Mathematica that would be
widely applicable because it wasn't
stuck on any particular computational
framework but rather was the the ER the
basis of all computation yeah I mean you
know I what I thought I was doing at the
time when I did it is not what I've
understood I was doing decades later but
you know projecting backwards uh when I
you know I had done physics when I was a
teenager in so on and uh partical
physics and cosmology and things like
that and you know the one of the one of
the things that is always a challenge
there is doing the calculations and I
had wanted to automate that and then
sometime it was around end of 1979 so
ancient times yeah I kind of was like I
want to make it as automatic as possible
to do the kinds of computations that I
and other people want to do and the
question was how do you do that and I
guess from my life in Natural Science
kind of the obvious thing to do was try
and find The Primitives the underlying
sort of atomic uh elements of
computation but what I I mean projecting
backwards so to speak one of the things
that's a challenge is what is
computationally possible is vastly
broader than what we humans care about
yeah so what you know first step is how
do you represent what is computationally
possible that's actually rather easy
much more challenging is to build the
bridge from the way that we think about
things to the what's computationally
possible and that's been kind of my
lifetime activity of sort of building a
computational language a notation for
computation that is convenient for us
humans and that can tap into this kind
of reservoir of power in the
computational universe and that's been
so that would be my kind of way in
modern times of explaining what what
I've been doing for the last 40-some
years yeah for sure you know I think
many people who are watching this or
will watch this subsequently they have
made use of the tools that you have
built but perhaps for the one or two in
the audience that perhaps have not let
me just note you know from a personal
perspective it's not just that the tools
that you have provided I'm speaking of
mathematic in particular allows us to do
things more easily it allows us to do
computations that we would not have the
boldness to even contemplate doing
without having the tool in place and I'm
thinking specifically years ago when I
was doing work in string theory that was
trying to use something that I
thankfully played a role in development
called mirror symmetry to calculate what
were known as a number of rational
curves on certain cabial manifolds right
the calculations we could set them up
but without a tool like Mathematica it
would be virtually impossible to
actually carry forward with them but you
know with what you had we could set it
up and hit a a button and sit back and
the Machine would just spit out number
after number after number calculating
exactly what we were seeking so more
yeah yeah yeah it's but the beautiful
thing is what you're willing to attempt
to undertake can be profoundly impacted
by the tools at your disposal it's it's
a very nonlinear process between the two
yeah I mean the way I see what I'm
trying to do is to give people a way to
think computationally about things it's
kind of like in the analog in
mathematics was before kind of 500 years
ago or something when you wanted to talk
about mathematics you just be using
words in natural language yeah and then
people started inventing mathematical
notation of plus signs and equal signs
and things and then it all got very
streamlined and you could start to
actually you could have a mathematical
language in which to think
mathematically and that's you know got
algebra and calculus and then all the
mathematical Sciences and so on and you
know kind of what I see as our mission
is to provide that kind of computational
notation that kind of computational
language of thinking about things
computationally and I think the uh the
thing that when we say what what does it
mean to think computationally about
things it's kind of like we Define rules
for how things work and then we see the
consequences of those rules and that's a
that's a very general kind of activity
and the question of sort of what types
of rules are ones that for example
relate to the kinds of things that we
humans care about that's kind of the art
of Designing a computational language is
to be able to represent those kinds of
things I mean but do you imagine and
we'll get into this when we when we turn
to physics in just a moment but just
speaking more
generally you know at some point we have
some conversation with some
extraterrestrial civilization and we ask
them about you know how do you go about
trying to quantify or to think more
deeply about the nature of the
challenges that reality presents you
will they do you think have the same
computational basis as we do or is it
just a quirk of our evolutionary process
that we think about the world in a
particular way and that gives us one
slice through the computational universe
yeah I mean this is a this is a bigger
conversation but I I think this this
whole kind of idea about you know can
you think about the world being built
from Rules
I think that's a very general idea I
think that the way in which you package
those rules and the way that you kind of
perceive and think in terms of those
rules that's pretty specific and so my
my tendency is to say for example if you
say well we talk about the
extraterrestrials you know the alien
intelligences and so on my feeling is
there are alien intelligences all around
us you know the weather famously is
supposed to have a mind of its own and I
think in many real senses it does it's
just that that mind mind is not well
aligned with the kind of mind that we
have if we look at you know the neuron
firings in our brains they're following
physical laws they're doing what they do
if you look at the fluid dynamics in the
atmosphere it's following physical laws
it's doing what it does and the question
is can we say that the stuff going on in
our brains is in some fundamental sense
more sophisticated than what's going on
in the atmosphere I don't think so I
think the issue is that what's going on
in our brains is kind of our perception
of kind of this
this notion of intelligence it's aligned
in a particular direction it's different
from the alignment of you know the the
the fluid dynamics in the atmosphere or
whatever else so I tend to think that
this this question of you ask sort of
will the aliens so to speak have the
same view of computation I think at the
lowest level it's kind of things are
operating according to rules if you ask
kind of how would what what is the
internal Narrative of the aliens the
internal Narrative of the the weather
the internal narrative for our brains
those are different and you know this is
the sort of the essence of what we do
when we do science is we try and take
the natural world as it is out there and
we try and kind of put it into a
narrative that we humans can understand
I mean that's what when we say we're
making a theory for something you know
the thing out there is just doing what
it does the question is do we have a way
with it within our minds within our way
of thinking about things to kind of talk
about what it's doing so to speak but um
but along those lines I I can't help and
I I I I hope that you're willing to sit
for a little while because I'd like to
pursue this just for a moment and then
get to the real topic of our
conversation here because I don't think
they're separate actually I think
there's a deep connection between it all
but you talk about the internal
representation or the internal
experience and I think that is for most
people what distinguishes our kind of
computation from the computation of the
weather right I don't think most people
I mean Thomas Nagel had this famous
dictum that if you're wanting to
describe Consciousness you should ask
the question what is it like to be that
thing you know what is it like to be a
human we have a reasonable good
understanding of that because we are of
that category what is it like to be a
bat right does a bat have an inner World
Of Consciousness and we can certainly
imagine that the answer to that question
is yes even though it's very difficult
to put ourselves into the mind of a bat
but when it comes to the weather I think
most people would resist the idea that
there is a what it is like to be the
weather do you think there is a what it
is like to be the weather yes I mean I
think that you know if we look at all
any of us ever know is our own personal
internal experiences yeah even the
extrapolation to you know another
human's experiences very tough is just
an you know empathetic extrapolation and
by the way when you are imagining what a
human with a different coming from a
different time in his history or with a
different kind of set of educational or
cultural backgrounds and so on is it's
not completely trivial to take your
inner thinking patterns and project them
and you know if you start thinking about
uh you know what's it like to be a
computer you know you start thinking
about what is the experience of a
computer from the time it's booted up to
the time it crashes it's kind of like a
human lifespan it remembers certain
things it has certain experiences maybe
somebody you know plugs a peripheral
into some Port it has some horrible
all kinds of all kinds of things like
this it is as you trace it through it is
surprisingly and bizarrely similar an
external description to the kind of
thing that that we feel and I I think
it's it's one of these things where this
question of for example you talk about
laws of physics and there's this
question of we are projecting what is
actually happening out there in the
world into our particular kind of
internal representation of what's going
on and you know you were talking about
sort of the inevitability or not of the
laws of physics one of the things that's
been a huge surprise to me in the last
couple of years is that from what I can
tell there is in some sense a complete
inevitability of the core laws of 20th
century physics for observers Like Us in
other words if if we were not as we are
if we had different characteristics we
would believe that the world has laws
different from the ones that we believe
that it has but the thing that's been a
big surprise to me is that it turns out
that the you know you might say well
does it depend on the fact that we have
two eyes does it depend on this does it
depend on that it depends on on sort of
two very big things and one subsidiary
thing it depends on the fact that we are
computationally bounded observers of the
universe that is there's all this
computation going on in the universe but
to stuff it into our finite Minds we
need to sort of simplify it a lot that's
one thing the other thing that is uh uh
is that we believe we are persistent in
time that is even in you know we'll talk
about in in actual models of physics we
are in in you know our models we're made
of different atoms of space at every
moment in time yet we believe that we
have the single thread of experience
going through time and there's a third
thing actually which is we're a certain
size relative to the underlying stuff in
the universe for sure you know we're not
uh and the fact that for example to to
give a an example sort of close to the
kinds of things I think you've thought
about a long time you know our notion of
time and space depends a lot on how big
we are that is the fact that you know we
look around and we see you know 10 100
meters away and light comes to us from
that distance speed of light is pretty
fast and that means that you know in a
microsc a millionth of a second we'll
have seen what's around us our brains
process things are more like thousandth
of a second time scales so for us we see
the world as a series of kind of frames
of this is what space is like we we say
it's out there because we see it sort of
all at the same time but right if we
were for example if we thought a million
times faster replace our brain brain
Hardware with you know Digital
Electronics we'll think a million times
faster we would have a different point
of view because then you know the the
the scene that we're in if we were in
the same size scene it would be coming
to us in in time short compared to the
time it takes us to process it we think
of space more like time presumably if we
yes yeah yes I mean it's a so I mean
there are these aspects of kind of the
way we are as observers that cause us to
perceive the world the way we perceive
the world the big surprise to me has
been the very technical fact that the
big laws of 20th century physics
statistical mechanics second
thermodynamics you know general
relativity and quantum mechanics seems
so far as we can tell to be not optional
they are inevitable features of
observers like us this is what observers
like us will have to see as they sort of
try to understand what's out there in
the world which is to me remarkable I
mean we'll talk about this maybe more
but but you know this idea that it is
conceivable to not just wheel in the
laws of physics as a oh it happens to be
that way but to be able to say that at
least for observers like us the laws of
physics as we have discovered them are
inevitable now along those lines there
and again we will get into some of the
details but to characterize the phrase
observers like us you've made reference
to a few qualities yes you've made
reference to computationally bounded
you've made reference to the time scales
over which we process information say
being very slow compared to say the
speed of
light that those feel very general to me
it's almost hard for me to imagine a
non-comp computationally bounded obser
Observer I'm not sure what that Observer
now you'd say this of course is a
limitation of the fact that I am a
computationally bounded Observer I
presume but do you envision what a
non-comp computationally bounded
Observer would be well entire universe I
mean is it the universe has me no I'll
give you an example yeah so you know in
in this room there's air there's a bunch
of gas molecules large number of gas
molecules they're all bouncing around
they're all essentially Computing what
they're going to do next they have these
iions there's a little computation going
on for us there's no way we can imagine
following all those gas molecules of
course because we are computationally
bounded if we were not computationally
bounded we would say I I've got all
those gas molecules I know what they're
going to do I know that in you know 5
Seconds all this particular collection
of gas molecules that were over here are
going to wind up over there I I'm I'm
able to and so then I wouldn't for
example say oh it's just a gas with a
certain pressure and so on I would say I
know my friend this gas molecule is
going to do this particular thing right
but we could but we could be
computationally bounded and still be
able to do that it's just the bound on
our computational processing would have
to be much larger than what it currently
is that was the distinction right I mean
you don't need to be computationally
unbounded to do that you just need to be
able to take in a kind of data set
that's beyond our capacity well no but
you know you can and this is where kind
of it gets m but you know if you start
thinking about as you increase the size
of the thing you're looking at as you
increase the amount of time that that is
elapsing and so on you very quickly get
into the situation where if you are of
any bounded size you will blow out your
abilities so to speak so so this is the
question of whether so for example if we
look at the the long future of the
universe you know one thing people are
sometimes kind of disappointed about is
oh you know there'll be a heat death in
the universe eventually you know all
these processes all these organized
things that are happening in the
universe it's all going to just grind
down into random heat random you know
sort of motion of molecules that are
just completely random and people say
that's terrible that's the end of
everything that one might care about in
this kind of random soup uh in the
universe but if you were not
computationally bounded you wouldn't
think that of course you would say every
molecule I know where it's g go it's got
it whole history that you can sort of
read out from it right right so that's
an example of what it would be like to
be not computationally bounded sure you
would you would have a very different uh
view now I you know a thing that I find
very challenging is to think about what
it's like to not be like us so to speak
yeah and you know I've tried for example
these days with you know we have AIS
that um are well aligned with the way we
humans think about things so you know I
did an experiment recently you take an
AI that's been trained on a few billion
images that we humans have put out on
the web and it can generate images so
you say you know show me a picture of a
cat and a party hat yeah and it will
generate something which is sort of
typical of what we humans would think of
as being a cat and a party hat say okay
that's what that's that's a concept that
we humans understand now let's move in
kind of concept space which we can do
inside this AI you can say let's move in
concept space away from the concept of
cat and a party hat let's move into what
I was calling interc concept space the
space between the concepts that we
humans have named what's out there well
you can have the AI just generate a
picture of what's out there what's out
there is something that looks like it's
a picture what does it mean to us yeah
right now pretty much nothing it's just
some elaborate patterns some complicated
picture what is it well we can kind of
yak about it for a bit but doesn't
really have a resonance for us and if we
even go beyond that and we say let's
modify the AI let's change its mind so
to speak change the way its mind is
built and say what does it then think a
cat and a body hat looks like you get
these weird pictures which are very
non-human they're very they kind of
begin to sort of show us a little bit
what it's like to be a mind that is not
quite like a human mind yeah right and
and it's it's you know it's for me it's
a it's a great exercise in imagination
which I don't think I've sort of
succeeded in in mastering I I will say
one thing though about the sort of
intercon concept space you know one of
the things that's really really
interesting about that is even the most
basic way of sort of exploring into
concept space the concepts that we
humans have come up with represent one
part in a trillion trillion trillion
trillion trillion I have to go on with a
bunch of trillions there of what
possible yeah and and and then we ask
ourselves well will we ever get there
and what we realize is that's what the
progress of Science and the sort of Arc
of intellectual history is all about we
are gradually expanding in our domain in
kind of the space of Concepts we're
gradually sort of expanding the
paradigms that we think in terms of and
so on it's a slow process but that's the
that's kind of the the journey that we
can think of as being kind of the
Journey of Science and Mathematics and
these other kinds of areas yeah for sure
now look when I
began as a physicist and I have since
changed or shifted or matured I don't
know what the right word is but when I
began Life as a physicist I thought that
what I was engaging in was a search for
the abstract and objective laws that
were kind of out there governing you
know formation of stars the Big Bang
black holes and things of that sort and
many of my colleagues still speak that
way and they feel deeply that is what
the charge of being a physicist or a
scientist more generally is all about I
have shifted to a place where it feels
much closer to what you're saying I've
shifted to a place where where I view
what I do and my colleagues and you do
as trying to describe in concept space
in the language that makes sense to us
as human beings what's happening out
there I no longer feel like the
equations that we write down for general
relativity and quantum mechanics are
kind of operating out there which is
certainly the Prejudice that I had as a
younger person if I understand correctly
you are saying something quite Sim that
the goal of what we do as scientists is
to find the description that makes sense
to us as say these computationally
bounded observers with brains that
operate on time scales much shorter than
the speed of light and so on and so
forth to describe what's out there but
do you think that there is an out there
that is operating According to some laws
rules whatever we want to describe it
that is at work of course we're part of
the out there so I don't mean to sort of
jux expose the two in that way but is
there some fundamental set of rules
that's really operating or is it all
about finding the set of rules that do a
good job at describing your perceptions
well so I think there is a thing that's
out there we call it the ruad and it's a
weird very abstract thing it's not
surprising that it's an abstract thing
because it's a sort of a very
conceptually big thing what is it it's
it's essentially this object that is the
entangled limit of all possible
computations that's a very weird kind of
concept because usually you say what is
a computation well you set up these
rules they might be the rules for the
way that the microprocessor in your
computer works you feed in some input
you let the thing go crunch crunch
crunch for a while and then you get the
output that's essentially the process of
a single computation one of the things
that we can then ask is well let's say
we change the rules for the computation
and we do the same thing we feed in some
input we get some output we got
different things going on let's let
imagine that we could look at what
happens with all possible rules all
possible inputs one of the things you
say well how could you ever conclude
anything from that turns out that thing
has a rich structure not least because
two very different inputs and maybe even
two very different ways of computing
rules for computation can wind up
producing the same thing so you get this
complicated entangled object that is
represents kind of all possible
computations running let's say even from
an infinite time and looking at the sort
of entangled structure of all these
possible computations it's a very big
abstract thing one thing about it is
there's only one of it it's Unique it's
it is the case that in a sense once you
have this idea of describing things
according to rules you inevitably get
this object it is the limit of sort of
describing everything in terms of rules
and so it's it's not like you get to say
oh I'll have ruad number one no actually
I'll I'll pick ruad number seven instead
said there's only one of it and it's
kind of as inevitable as you know once
you've defined what you know two and two
are and pluses and so on it's inevitable
that 2 plus 2 equals 4 it's not a thing
where you get to say you know might it
be that way might it be a different way
it has to be the way it is so so so just
if I understand that space well enough
and perhaps how it relates to things
that have been articulated previously
you know when I was a student of Robert
knows philosopher at Harvard he had this
idea that he was developing at the time
called the principle of fecundity you
know it was sort of like all all
realities are out there in some way I
don't know if he framed it precisely
enough to draw a relationship but um max
tegmark you must know from MIT had this
idea of the larger reality being all
possible mathematical structures they're
just out there and we are cognizant of a
small slice of it is your
ruad commensurate with those
ideas who knows I mean I know what the
ruad is and it's a very nice precise
thing I have to say I've I've you know
it's interesting because one of the
things that's happened is you know we
got to this place by doing computation
and physics and Science and so on and
we've ended up with these constructs and
Concepts that are sort of deeply
philosophical almost theological in some
ways and and in many cases they sort of
they peel back you know the last 300 or
so years it's been kind of science has
been out ahead but some of the things
that we end up talking about are things
which you know theologians have talked
about for for centuries but have been
kind of submerged in modern science so
you know the thing the thing about sort
of the thing we built with the ruad is
it's a it's a a nice precise very well-
defined thing so so how it relates to I
mean people have asked me U the the
particular let's see I mean I I should
keep the inventory of all the things
that people ask is it related to XYZ
Because by the time you have this object
that purports to be the underlying thing
of all possible reality so to speak it
better be related to a lot of stuff but
so so the answer is I don't I don't
really have a great a great way to
address that I think that the the
concept I mean the the thing that um uh
you know you're asking kind of what's is
it out there and one of the things to
realize is and this is kind of a brain
twisting kind of thing as you were
alluding to there's no out there we're
in it yeah it is everything and we are
part of it so the the question is really
how does an observer within the ruad
made from the same stuff that makes the
ruad what does that Observer perceive
about the ruad and that the answer the
fact that there's anything reasonable
one can say about that I consider
remarkable and the point is that with
you know for an an arbitrary Observer
there's not much you can say but for an
observer with these limitations that we
seem to have being the way that we are
there are a bunch of things you can say
and what's really exciting is the things
you can say seem to align almost
perfectly with the big things that we
read B to say in 20th century physics
which is super surprising I mean it's
not what I thought was going to happen
at all and I think the uh you know this
question about how do you perceive a
thing when you're in that thing is a you
know that's a that's something where
we've sort of been lucky that that
thanks to mathematical physics basically
we have some of the tools necessary to
actually talk about that we understand
things like reference frames from
relativity we understand very things
about measurement from quantum mechanics
these are the things which are sort of
the raw material that gives us a hope of
sort of turning what would otherwise be
some kind of vague sort of philosophical
um you know concept into something that
we can actually sort of do hard science
with so I'd love to jump into to some of
the details but I'm wondering if at the
outset we could set expectations really
my expectations perhaps more than
anything I mean the reason I believe
that's not even the right word the
reason I have confidence in quantum
mechanics of course is I know how to sit
down with the basic mathematics and
given enough time and computational
power I know how to calculate things
like a scattering amplitude or the
anomalous dipole moment of the electron
you know so I can calculate things and I
know that when those calculations are
done correctly they agree to Fantastic
Precision with things that we actually
observe in the world I know how to sit
down with general relativity and
calculate the bending of Starlight by
the sun just to go all the way back to
1919 so where where does your program
stand before we get into the details can
you calculate like the the anomalous
Magnetic Moment of the electron no not
that but what we you know so here's
here's where we're at we can uh in the
case of Okay so we've got these three
areas statistical mechanics general
relativity quantum mechanics statistical
mechanics is actually the easiest to
talk about maybe we'll talk about it
later but which one statistical
mechanics is actually the easiest to
talk about it has um uh just but but in
general relativity for example uh we can
calculate so for example we have a nice
calculation now of the merging of two
black holes and it seems to agree well
with the predictions of general
relativity in fact it seems to agree
well enough that the method that we have
of computing uh so so so normally as as
you well know when you're Computing
something like merging of two black
holes you're studying kind of the all
these differential equations that
represent the kind of curvature of
SpaceTime and so on and when you
actually do it on a computer after
you've probably pre-processed it a bunch
with Mathematica but eventually you try
and discretize the SpaceTime so that you
can put it on on a digital computer yes
in our methods and we'll talk about this
in more detail we're starting from the
discrete underlying structure of
SpaceTime and we're then aggregating up
to see what consequences that has on a
large scale and turns out that the thing
we've built seems to be a very good way
of just Computing what happens in
general rots of a day so for instance
could you could you calculate you know
the gravitational waves that say ligo
observed say from the first looks like
yeah looks like it it's very convenient
that black holes oh yeah we got a nice
little video there that that um yeah let
we can we can show this yeah that's
that's what we're seeing we're seeing
two little very very tiny black holes
close in size to the elementary length
in the universe and there they merged
and if you sort of analyze this a bit
you'll find there were gravitational
waves that came out at that merger and
uh uh you know it's it's looking good in
terms of agreeing with what is predicted
from general relativity and observed do
you mean like the surface area is non
decreasing of the merged black hole that
sort of agreement but also also you can
look at the actual ring down uh and you
can look at and and it it seems right
and it's you know I think this is
something that is now getting much more
precisely validated because people
actually want to use our models uh as a
scheme for doing numerical relativity I
mean it's kind of funny because the
people who say this is a good scheme for
doing numerical relativity and for them
if it disagrees with numerical with with
standard relativity it's like oh that's
a really bad thing thing for us that's
really exciting because it gives us a a
kind of a a sort of a crack through
which to see kind of things like the
discreetness of space so in the case of
General altivity we're in I think pretty
good shape we have good agreement with
what you would expect from in the
domains where you expect agreement with
General and we have a lot of weird
effects which we haven't yet been able
to compute uh quite what their magnitude
should be quite how they work they
depend on one parameter whose value
don't know but we have a bunch of a
bunch of funky things we'll talk about
it things like Dimension fluctuations in
the universe the universe before we go
there just so on that on the image that
you showed yeah you you mentioned that
the size of the black holes was on par
with the elementary size of so these are
tiny black holes tiny black holes what
so what sets the scale in like in and
just again for the audience you know in
general relativity you know we have
various numbers that come in Newton's
constant if we're including the speed of
light that's a useful number to come in
if we're doing something that has
Quantum aspects to it we bring in h bar
from quantum mechanics we put those
together and we get a fundamental length
scale called the plank length about 10
to the minus 33 cmers a fundamental
energy scale the plank Mass about 10 to
the 19 times the mass of a proton a
fundamental time scale about you know 10
to minus 43 seconds the plank time so so
like where does any of of that come in
to well I mean that that all comes in I
mean we we we probably let me let me
give a little bit the status report
because you asked for that and then
let's get into explaining how the model
actually works because I think it's it's
um so you know general relativity nice
check mark we we really have you know we
can really see how things align with
General but what those tiny black holes
like do they Hawking radiate oh that's a
good question we are we are just working
on that it's looking very promising it's
but but now you're asking and again I
have to explain a bunch more because
what you saw there was a classical
picture yeah right we actually have the
sort of full Quantum version but it is
you know for the universe that's the
computation the universe does for us
it's very difficult to do that
computation it's a lot of computation
but yes in our models there absolutely
is the I mean we can't yet say we get
the you know Hawking temperature and all
that kind of thing um it is pretty
promising that we get er equals epr
which which we can explain what what
that all is um it's it's very clear kind
of how the ads CFT correspondence Works
in our models things like that um again
you know technical stuff we can get to
it how about the singularity how about
the black hole Singularity does you do
you get any insight into that yes I mean
well we should we should we're going
into the because I mean the the the you
know because we have discreete SpaceTime
the world of singularities is a bit
different than it is in continuous
SpaceTime so for example topology change
is very easy in a discrete SpaceTime and
we absolutely see that so um but but
let's you know just in terms of where
we're at so um sort of generality pretty
good shape uh quantum mechanics we can
do a good job of reproducing sort of
standard Quantum information Quantum
circuits type quantum mechanics and in
fact you can even take a Quantum circuit
and you can compile it into our models
do computations at that level and
actually you get somewhat better more
efficient ways to optimize Quantum
circuits than we've had before so that's
that works okay Quantum field Theory
wait can you do particle in a box I'm
just wondering I mean can you do the
basic well okay so the one thing I kind
of enlighted there particles are tough
for us we don't yet know and we'll
explain how this works but but kind of
particles for us are like if you had a
fluid like water or something you can
have a little Eddie on the surface of
the water and those are kind of like
what we think particles are in our
models and figuring out what the
spectrum of particles like electrons and
photons and quarks and so on is in our
models no we have not been able to do
that yet we we know the path to do that
but it is technically complicated and
we're just working up to it um I think
that the I mean one of the things that's
amazing about these models is usually
you make a model for something you kind
of compare it with experimental data say
oh whoops that piece of the model
doesn't quite work let me tweak the
model to fix that and so on we're now at
you know three and a half years out and
we are zero tweaks that is there's not a
single thing where we've said oops you
know the model doesn't agree with this
let's change the model it is very hard
work to go from the underlying model to
the actual observable characteristics of
physics but the thing that's just
amazing as far as I'm concerned is that
as I say we're at zero tweaks yeah you
know there's no oh whoops you know the
thing predicts we have different number
of Dimensions than we do etc etc etc
there's no I mean I having said that we
don't know why the universe is has
appears to us right now to have three
dimensions we can't derive the number
three or three or three large dimensions
perhaps what's that yeah three large
dimensions right and and we you know we
can talk about what uh uh the question
of so so one of the things that has
happened is a lot of different
approaches in mathematical physics like
you know causal set theory spin Networks
High triangulations I presume yes
dynamical triangulations these are all
things that we can see are limits of our
models the one that's still out there is
string theory which I'm pretty sure is
also a limit of our models but that just
that mathematical physics hasn't been
done it'll be very nice when it is done
and what's really cool about about
seeing this correspondence with with
existing work in mathematical physics is
that you know there's a there's a lot
that's been achieved there and so we can
just sort of plug in the things that
have been achieved and learn more about
our models and also provide interesting
foundations for what's been done in
other areas of mathematical physics I
mean like for example in uh uh causal
set theory for example people just say
oh there are events that happen in
different places in SpaceTime it's
always been kind of confusing why would
relativity work given that there sort of
these random events at different places
in SpaceTime in our models there are
events at different places in SpaceTime
but they are kind of algorithmically
generated and the way in which they're
generated inevitably gives relativity so
you get to kind of talk about about
things using the the sort of Machinery
of of coal set theory but now you've got
a foundation that says there isn't this
big problem that they used to be and you
can kind of you know work from there I
you briefly you you were about to say
something about Quantum field Theory so
could you finish that yeah yeah so so I
mean the thing that as I say we can uh
the next challenge we're working on
right now is doing the same kind of
thing for Quantum field theory that
we've been able to do for general
relativity that is starting from the
underlying model and just doing a bunch
of computation and being able to
reproduce features of quantum field
Theory and it's pretty clear what the
road map for doing that is it's just
technically difficult can I ask you a
quick question on that and again we're
going a little nonlinear here but that's
fine our audience is used to that to me
quantum mechanics is quantum field
theory in 0 plus one
dimensions and Quantum field Theory as
you normally describe it is therefore
just quantum mechanics in say a
signature n comma one reality you know n
plus1 Dimensions why would it be you
know from what I understand that you're
going to describe dimensionality is so
fluid in your approach I would have
thought that going from quantum
mechanics to Quantum field theory is
like no no problem at all okay so here's
what happens and and we're now we are
definitely jumping around here there's a
there when we think about quantum
mechanics we're thinking about these
many possible Paths of history and
that's kind of the the defining feature
of quantum mechanics is is it's not that
definite things happen it's that there
are many parts of history and we just
get to observe certain Aggregates of
those parts of History so in our models
the the simplest case that corresponds
to to sort of minimal sort of quantum
information style quantum mechanics
looks at those different Paths of
history and just says take the whole
universe and say there's this path of
history for the whole universe take the
whole universe these kinds of things
okay that that is a very wasteful way to
represent things and it doesn't deal
with the spatial degrees of freedom of
what's going on if you try and do that
sort of more less wastefully and you say
no I don't just want to say there's a
whole you know complete state of the
universe and it branches to another
complete state of the universe but you
want to get inside there and say well
actually it's just this little tiny
piece of the universe that's different
between these two branches and you're
dealing with space which is the thing
that you know so what's happening is
most of space is unchanged there's just
this tiny part of space that's changed
it's just technically more difficult to
do that and and so that's why there's a
distinction between kind of quantum
mechanics in the sort of quantum
information style of doing quantum
mechanics and this you know Quantum
field Theory where there is a a spatial
extent that one has to deal with and one
actually is talking about you know
scattering processes and particles that
are moving I mean for example in our
models we maybe come to this the the
idea that motion is possible is
non-trivial in other words the fact that
you can take a thing and move it to
somewhere else and it's still the same
thing is not obvious right I mean in you
know in traditional general relativity
if you're close to A Spacetime
Singularity you know any material thing
that you try and move there is going to
get shredded and it's probably not the
same thing right so but but in our
models the possibility of motion is
something you have to derive and and so
we can derive it for things like black
holes we need to find out for what other
things we can Define it and those other
things for which we can Define it those
are particles basically
because particles are the are the
carrier carriers of identity that
survive under through time and through
space right and that's but but you know
Finding what those are is is just you
know technically difficult so so so can
you take us back now more to the
beginning this is sort of a good summary
chaotic though it may have been because
of my random questions and I apologize
for that but if we take a step back now
where does it begin I I've done a little
bit of reading but no doubt I am
incompletely read in on the subject but
it presumably it begins with just some
collection of nodes and Rule yeah go
ahead what what is you know what's the
universe made of so to speak yeah and
you know the that's been a thing people
have discussed since Antiquity and you
know is it made of discret atoms is it a
continuous thing the that was something
much debated right what what a what is
matter made of
okay we discovered you know something
years ago it's made of discret molecules
we definitively know that light same way
you know we can think of it as made of
photons space on the other hand we have
tended to assume is continuous we've
assumed that space is just this
background thing and we can put stuff
anywhere we want in space kind of the
starting point for our models is space
is not just this background thing space
is actually made of stuff and in fact
everything in the universe we can think
of as being features of space and so in
in fact the the the way that there are
many equivalent ways to think about this
because it's a deeply abstract thing but
the way that I think is most kind of we
talked about what is the role of science
about sort of you know converting what's
out there in the world to human
understandable narratives the best one I
know for explaining this is is the
following to just say what space is made
of is kind of these discrete atoms of
space which are things where the only
thing you can say about them is they
have an identity they're they they are
distinct from each other and then the
other thing you can say is how those
atoms of space are related to each other
so in other words we can say this atom
of space is related to these two other
atoms of space what do we get when we
have this whole big collection of
relations we can represent that as a
kind as a graph where we're saying it's
kind of like a friend Network what's the
friend network of the atoms of space so
to speak and maybe in our universe today
there might 10 to 400 atoms of space
we're not sure but but it's a very large
number you talk about in the observ in
the observable universe presumably in
the observable universe and the full
ruad is much bigger than that yeah um
the the universe as we've sliced it and
so on um but uh but then this so so
we've got this giant Network that uh has
um you know these these atoms of space
related in these ways and so then the
and that's kind of what we think
everything in in the universe is made of
and so for example particles are these
well black holes for example are
particular regions that have certain
characteristics that correspond to the
way the black holes work particles are
these things that are kind of like
topologically knotted up pieces of that
Network we think that have some kind of
you know continued identity so that's
kind of the idea of that's what's that's
what the universe is made of it's kind
of interesting to me as a historical
matter that back you know beginning of
the 20th century many people had the
belief that space was discreet in fact I
I keep on discovering that many of those
famous physicists that uh we both know
about you know I keep on discovering you
know Heisenberg thought that space was
discret B thought that space was
discreet Einstein thought that space was
discreet it was um 1916 Einstein has
this nice letter where he says in the
end it will turn out that space is
discreet really but we don't yet have
the tools necessary to see how that
works huh I mean I would understand it
well for for all the other luminaries
that you made reference to because the
discreetness of reality was emerging
with a Vengeance through the studies in
quantum mechanics I Einstein 2
photoelectric effect you know the
discreet nature life but I had no idea
that he actually thought that when it
came to SpaceTime i' love to see that so
offline I'll get the reference yeah yeah
right no it's it's a um uh but but so
you know and what happened at the time
was nobody could get kind of their
discrete models of space to agree with
relativity yeah and um it was you know
and I'm not surprised given what we now
know it it required another few layers
of kind of paradigmatic thinking so to
speak to be able to get something where
that was not difficult to achieve But
but so okay so in our models sort of
what's there in the universe is this
giant Network that represents kind of
the state state of the universe the
state of space everything in the in in
in the universe is a feature of space so
then the question is what about time and
you know one of the things that was sort
of the uh you know people have tended to
say is oh space and time are the same
kind of thing and I think Einstein
actually thought that so much minkovski
was the was the but he bought into
minkowski's view pretty pretty quickly
and pretty fully right right makovski
though was the one who is like we can
make this SpaceTime object and it's has
very nice mathematical properties and so
on but but so I don't think space and
time are anything like the same kind of
thing I think they're very different
kinds of things I think time we can
think of as sort of the inexorable
progress of computation so time is this
thing where we're applying the rules and
we keep on applying them we keep on
applying them that successive
application of rules that is the pro
progress of time and so in the case of
these models what happens is you've got
this giant Network and you have these
rules that say if you have a little
piece of network that looks like this
rewrite it to a piece of network that
looks like that you just keep doing that
over and over again and time is defined
by those Progressive rewritings now that
the the so then the question is when you
do that for a very big Network and you
do that for a very long period of time
many many rewritings what is the the
aggregate what what do you see in
aggregate it's kind of like asking you
know these molecules are bouncing around
at a microscopic scale what will be the
large scale sort of behavior of the
system and we know in the case of
molecules bouncing around oh it's fluids
like water and so on that's what you get
from this sort of large scale structure
so the question is what do you get from
this graph it's actually a hyper graph
we tend to use um and you know these
rewrite rules and so on what do you get
what's the large scale limit well with
various footnotes that we can talk about
the answer is the large scale limit is
Einstein's equations for space time and
and are you talking about the vacuum
equations no no it's the it's the full
equations but but you have to say what
so okay so just to fill that in so I
mean remember I'm saying everything in
universe is made of space so when we get
energy for example and matter they are
just features of space and we have to
characterize what it means to have a
piece of space that is representing
matter and energy and mass and so on and
turns out and this is something really
surprised me that energy turns out to be
basically the density of updates
happening in this network I mean there's
a slightly more formal definition that's
a flux of causal edges through space
likee hypersurfaces but basically it's
the amount of updating that's happening
in the network that characterizes the
the density of energy associated with
that part of the network and so then
then we ask questions like okay here's
here's an example of something that you
can ask is you say let's let's talk
about gravity how does gravity work well
so you know we can talk about if in the
absence of gravity uh you know things
move on shortest paths so you know we
have gd6 shortest paths from here to
there in a graph it's pretty easy to
Define what a shortest path is because
it's just from every node you just have
an edge you follow that until you get to
some other Edge so you have this the
shortest path now you ask in this model
what happens when there's a bunch of
activity in the network and it turns out
that that deflects shortest paths the
gd6 are changed by this activity in the
network and the way they're changed is
exactly according to the Einstein
equations according to standard laws of
gravity and that's so so can you just
can you just abuse me of a couple of
worries that immediately yes come to
mind so worry number one is again you
know we'll talk of various levels of
sophistication so I hope the audience
will bear with us but you know in
general relativity as many in the
audience know we describe space time
continuously as some manifold on which
there's a distance function so-called a
metric yep and usually as we describe it
we try to solve the Einstein equations
to figure out what the metric is the
distance function on that space but of
course we could always say that any
metric is a solution to the Einstein's
equation simply by defining the rightand
side to be what comes out of the
Einstein tensor for the given metric
that you put in so trivially metric as a
solution to the Einstein's equation from
that perspective the only time it
becomes non-trivial is if you have an
independent definition of the leftand
side and the right hand side but if
everything for you is a feature of
SpaceTime do you have an independent
definition on the left and the right
hand side or is it just topology right
so so the fact that I'm describing what
energy is is that Independence so to
speak and also the fact that for example
in that black hole simulation those are
vacuum solutions to the Einstein
equations there is no separate kind of
you know separate place where we're
identifying I mean you know where
subject to particular boundary
conditions exactly yes yes that had to
be set up with with very particular
boundary conditions but I mean just to
just to give some kind of sketch of how
things emerge so we've got this giant
Network and the question is how do you
extract from that something that seems
like continuous space okay so first
thing you have to do is this network it
just says how all the atoms of space are
related it doesn't for example tell you
like where the atoms of space are
there's no where yet and so first thing
you have to do is start defining you
know what is the effective dimension of
the space that this represents so you
can do that by saying start at a
particular position in this network go
to all the nodes that are distance one
from that in terms of just following one
Edge in the graph oh and calculate the
volume or something of the calculate the
the volume of the GD basic ball the
volume of what you get to if you go R
steps right and as that grows if if the
leading term is R the power D then you
can identify d as the dimension right
okay then you look at the subleading
term and there's a correction to the art
of the D growth and that correction is
proportional to the Richie Scala
curvature so that's that's telling you
that that correction tells you the you
know a measure of the curvature of space
right so by doing things like that you
can kind of see how to tease out from
this ultimately very discrete structure
you can kind of tease out kind of the
the the standard Continuum things and
you get to the the um you know the the
Richie tensor for example comes out in a
nice way it's again a little bit more
tricky because you're dealing with a
space-time Richie tensor you're dealing
with these light cones that you have to
construct in this kind of space as a
function of time and so on so it's it's
you know there's some technical now just
to explain the technical complexity of
this is when you talk about a manifold a
manifold is kind of a representation of
geometry where you look microscopically
microscopically microscopically it's
just geometry in the way that uid
defined geometry it's ukian uh space in
our case you look microscopically
microscopically there's just a
hypergraph down there there's no
underlying ukian likee space and so we
kind of have to build our own new
version of Geometry we're calling it for
now infr geometry where we start from
this this underlying structure and we
have to build up the features of
differential geometry from that and we
we are we're sort of Midway through
doing a fairly rigorous kind of
development of kind of what is you know
what is geometry like when it isn't
based on a manifold based on uking space
and by the way that answers questions
like what is the curvature tensor like
in three and a half dimensional space
nobody there is no literature I I I'd be
thrilled if you tell me there literature
on this we found no literature on the
subject I mean this is this is not a
thing people have ever you know had had
reason or ability to explore yeah
analytic we can analytically continue
you know sometimes you need to do that
when certain integrals are not well
defined but I don't think we've ever
really grappled no I mean in in Quantum
field Theory you know we do a little bit
of dimensional you know four minus
Epsilon dimensions and so on but uh uh
but in the in the case of differential
geometry that's not what's been explored
here's wor number two if don't if you
don't yeah please go ahead so Einstein
famously spent 10 years writing down or
figuring out what ultimately are the
Einstein field equations that he
famously gave the world in November of
1915 when we look back on what Einstein
wrote down with hindsight of course it's
kind of pretty obvious that it had to be
once once you're dealing with curvature
and once you're dealing with energy
momentum as described by the this
particular symmetric two tensor there
aren't that many things that you can put
on the left hand side so in fact you
could put them all there and just label
them by the number of derivatives that
they have keep the ones with the lowest
number of derivatives then just impose
some conservation equation and pretty
much that gets you to the Einstein
equation so what worries me is getting
those equations
out perhaps is less impressive to me
than it should be and maybe you can get
me to the point of being really
impressed because there's not much that
it could have been because presumably
you're going for the lowest order piece
we could talk about higher order
corrections as well absolutely but
there's not much that it could have been
besides armuu minus a half gunu r on the
left hand side yeah you're right the the
thing that we didn't know is how to go
from something lower level to that in
other words it's just like saying you
look at the fluid equations for you know
how a bunch of gas molecules or you know
liquid molecules or something what the
aggregate behavior of those things is in
that case also there's not much else it
could be the Navia Stokes equations are
sort of inevitable given given certain
characteristics but in that case it was
a non-trivial thing even given the Navia
Stokes equations they were known long
before we knew that molecules existed
but knowing that what's underneath there
is a bunch of molecules bouncing around
that's a thing that's worth knowing and
and that's that's that's you're right
that for me also the Einstein equations
seem obvious um you know it's it's kind
of uh um and and in fact the same is
true of quantum mechanics in our models
quantum mechanics seems obvious as well
but the fact is that that the uh you
know the fact that it's been possible to
derive this from something first of all
lower level just this kind of discrete
machine code and more extremely than
that this ruad object that is kind of a
necessary thing the fact that it's
possible to derive these things from
that that to me is rather remarkable
yeah and and let me just to fill in a
little bit about about sort of how to
think about this let's talk about you
know the the thing that I said was going
to be the easiest one of the three big
theories of 20th century physics namely
statistical mechanics okay so so you
know the big result of statistical
mechanics is the second law of
Thermodynamics the law of entropy
increase the the rule that says the law
that says if you start Systems off in a
kind of orderly State they will tend to
degrade to disorder or they they will
you know if you have a bunch of
molecules and they're all going in the
same direction and kind of doing
mechanical work pushing in the same
direction chances are things will
randomize and it will turn into heat
yeah and and that's so that's been
that's the second law and people have
wondered could you derive the second law
in fact Einstein interestingly something
I I just learned you may have known this
for a long time in 1905 Einstein wrote
these three amazing papers that
established you know relativity quantum
mechanics and Brownian motion yeah um
the uh and the size the size of Adam's
mon but so it's really four I like to
count the four of them but anyway go
ahead okay that that's interesting okay
the question is what were the papers
that Einstein wrote in the three years
leading up to that time in 1905 the
answer is Einstein wrote papers trying
to prove the second Ro of theramic and
the papers were wrong they were they
were philosophically interesting they
very much followed boltzman um the who
had been kind of the person who was
originally pushing the idea of sort of
molecular theory of gases early
derivations of the second law and so on
yeah and Einstein sort of thought he
could derive the second law he didn't
succeed he used the same kind of almost
philosophical approaches to science and
applied them in these other areas and
you know amazing results so to speak
that's just a footnote to history yeah
but but um you know people believe that
the Second Law would be derivable that
is if you knew the mechanics of the
molecules that would it would be
inevitable that you would get this
tendency towards randomization it's very
confusing like boltzman for example had
his uh H theorem H the for sure that
said oh well if you have these molecules
bouncing around this quantity H which is
well basically the entropy will increase
with time well H will decrease with time
the entropy will increase with time but
but the problem is you put in the input
the output if you look at it more
closely of course yes yeah right exactly
I mean the the you know the thing that's
mysterious about this is that if you
look at the individual collisions of
molecules they are reversible in time
yeah there's nothing you know you look
at the little movie of the of the
billiad balls bouncing you could run it
backwards you wouldn't know the
difference yeah right but in aggregate
when you look at all those gas molecules
you absolutely can tell things go from
orderly initial states to disordered
final States yeah and and the question
is why do we believe that and and the
answer is because we are observers of
the kind we are and and here's how to
think about it I think that is because
we are computationally bounded observers
even though there is in principle you
know we can think of it as sort of an
encryption process we start off with the
simple initial condition then we're
doing all this computation and that's
grinding up that initial condition into
something that looks to us encrypted and
random if we were sufficiently
computationally sophisticated we'd be
able to say hey I understand what that
is I can reverse it and see that it came
from that simple initial condition but
because we're computationally bounded we
don't get to do that and so in fact the
the phenomenon of the second law is a
consequence of a very computational kind
of thing it's a consequence okay so the
there's one more piece that I have to
explain but but before you get to that
detail and I hope I'm not throwing you
off track but there is something that's
confusing about what you just said maybe
you can clarified in half a second so I
agree with you that this being that did
not suffer from the limitations that we
have would see all the molecules and all
the trajectories and be able to
immediately reverse it and recognize
where it came from and so on and so
forth but that being would also have the
capacity to say hey there is a more
useful way to think about this too I'm
not going to erase my capacity to see
all the molecules in their trajectories
but coar graining seems to be a useful
tool for me to use so that I can have a
language that talks about the molecules
just filling the room as opposed to the
trajectory of each individual molecule
and for some discourse it's useful to
have that approximation that course
gring the being would still be able to
do that they would not necessarily be
wedded to the level of detail that would
put the second law of Thermodynamics out
of business that's true but they you
know the issue and this is this relates
to kind of the the the march of Paradigm
so to speak there are things that we
would now say oh it's obvious you
describe this aspect of the world this
way but you know looked at with
different instruments you know looked at
without a telescope looked at without
whatever we would just describe the
world differently yes and you know I
think that that the the saying that oh
yes you could aggregate this and say oh
well it's just roughly this going on the
the computationally unbounded being
might say why would you want to do that
I can figure out everything why would I
need to look at this aggregate thing
that's irrelevant I it's kind of like
there are plenty of situations where you
know as we've you know in the Practical
world where we get more and more data
about things one might have said oh I
don't know take some some medical you
know Finding you know you might have
said oh you know you look pale today
well okay that we can convert that in
modern times to this is the precise
metabolomics that we can measure of this
and that and the other and you know and
and then the oh you look pale today
doesn't seem like the most relevant
thing to say so to speak and so I think
it's it's hard to project you're
absolutely right there's nothing that
would prevent sort of an entity that can
do this unbounded computation from
deciding to aggregate things in that way
on the other hand it's it's you know
it's a it's a the fact that we are led
to aggregate things in the way that we
do is a consequence of the way that we
are for sure but but you know I should
explain one one other very important
piece which is this phenomenon I call
computational irreducibility which is
something that I I mean I started
figuring out in the in the early 1980s
actually and it's the following thing so
so one of the kind of sort of ideas that
one gets from mathematical physics is
once you've got the equation you've
solved the problem more or less right I
mean that is that the equation it's like
I've got it now and I can work out every
consequence from that when you're in the
computational world that's no longer
true in the same sense you've got some
rules you start running the rules you
say because to run the rules will take
so long that you can't do it any faster
than running the rules right right and
so this this this fact that you can't
jump ahead and say and the answer is
going to be X you have to just run every
step and see what happens that's kind of
a a new feature of the computational
world a little different than we'd ever
understood in the mathematical world I
mean by the way it's not like people
hadn't intuitively understood this I
mean you know Newton for example
famously said you know the the um uh
when when you're talking about many
planets in the solar system you know he
says he' now got the equations but to
work out the motion of all these planets
is I think he said if I'm not mistaken
beyond the the capability of any human
mind he thought God could do it but no
human mind could do it so he already had
this idea of kind of the the sort of
irreducible computational difficulty of
working out the consequences of things
but we see that much more extremely in
these computational settings and that's
by the way that's sort of the that's
what time that's the sort of hard aspect
of time so to speak that time the
passage of time means something because
it is an irreducible computation you
know we we get to live our lives and do
all the things we do and we can't just
jump ahead and say and the answer is
going to be 47 or something um we have
to kind of live the time to uh it means
something to live the time so to speak
so we can lack free will but we can
never predict what we're going to do so
it all works out yes exactly so right I
think but but so so the the you know in
this case of of of the second law the
thing that's very critical is this
underlying computational irreducibility
if it wasn't for the fact that it is
difficult to do that decryption of what
happened if that was still easy then
there wouldn't be any we wouldn't say oh
it looks random we would just say oh
it's obvious you know I can I can see
it's this so it's this interplay between
the computational irreducibility of
what's going on underneath and our
computational limitations in our ability
to observe things and that's what that's
what kind of gives us in this case the
second law now you know once you've
understood those principles it's kind of
obvious the second law has to work right
um but before you understand those
things I mean if you read I I spent a
bunch of effort really untangling the
history of the Second Law and and the
incredible confusions that that
developed because people didn't
understand these kind of essentially
computational principles because they
were 100 Years too early to understand
those things and yes you know the thing
that's great and and always you know
very encouraging when you have some
model and you figure things out and so
on if you can go back at the end and say
that was obvious that's a huge win right
you know if you say um no you know you
have to you know pile all these Stones
up and just a exactly this way and then
eventually you get this big tower that's
much less satisfying than if you say
well I should have been able to see that
long ago sure and that's kind of more
the situation we're in now now having
said that the you know when you ask
about like what are the experimental
implications and so on figuring out you
know what is the dimension flu the
consequence of uh Dimension fluctuations
that's a bunch of just difficult physics
work so let me give you an example of
how that works so in our models probably
the universe started infinite
dimensional and gradually it kind of
cooled down to be effectively
threedimensional it's as if we had this
initial Network where everything was
connected to everything and then
gradually it got to be more like three
dimensions where you know there's it's
things can be far apart so to speak but
when you say early just kind I get a
feel here do you envision early on
there's like a primordial node or is
there some primordial configuration how
does it begin ah yes well that's a
that's a fun thing in the in the life of
the ruad because um
it's okay so if
we J okay there's
a the ruad in a sense has no beginning
but in a sense it is you have to talk
about it the object itself is just uh
what can I say it's kind of like a
circle
where's the beginning of the circle it's
like well if we are actually going to
draw the circle on a piece of paper then
there's a beginning to it but
conceptually there's no beginning to it
yeah it's it's just is and it's the same
thing here and when we a thing to
understand about this is that that we as
as we are observers in embedded in this
ruad we can be at different positions in
the ruad so let's talk about that in
terms terms of ordinary space so we have
physical space and we have a certain
view about what's happening in the
universe our view of what's happening in
the universe depends on where we are you
know we're on this planet in this galaxy
etc etc etc if we were somewhere else we
have would have a different view of
what's going on now more abstractly in
the ruad we a mind so to speak is at
some place in the ruad different minds
are in effect at different places in the
ruad different Minds attribute in a
sense different sets of rules to what
happened in the universe there is a
notion of motion in the ruad just like
there's Motion in physical space just
like as we move to a different place
we're still the same us there is a
similar kind of concept of motion in the
ruad that we can say there is this
entity and there's another entity nearby
and these two entities will have sort of
corresponding views of what's Happening
um you know when we talk about sort of
alien intelligences we can think about
that as more distant things things in
the ruad it's like all humans are
clumped in this little little just as we
are clumped on this little planet so to
speak we're also clumped in a small
region of the ruad all our minds are
concentrated in the small region of the
ruad as we go to you know your cat or
dog or something it's a little bit
further away as we go to the weather for
example it's much further away and sort
of communicating across the ruad
translating from one place in Ral space
to another is not so easy and so that's
why kind of it it you know there's not
good alignment between these different
things yeah but but I think in in uh uh
let's see you were asking about sort of
the beginning of things yeah so if we
stick to physical space for a moment can
you describe to us how in your approach
a space resembling ours can be built up
and I and I saw some animation that you
had that may assist in giving people
yeah yeah right we can look at let's see
what was this this was uh
number one there can try so tell us what
we're seeing here okay so this is just a
possible beginning of our universe so if
we if we start it again at the very
beginning we'll we it'll start off from
just one node and it'll keep on being
Rewritten building up new nodes and new
nodes and so on and this is you know a
ridiculously small amount of effectively
time at the beginning of the universe so
to speak and there's a very simple rule
for starting with an node and what to do
next exactly and you keep going long
enough and you will get even with this
particular rule you'll get something
which has kind of the the the the in
aggregate seems like continuous space
just like if we had enough molecules
bouncing around it would seem like a
continuous fluid and so and and and in
here you can apply your technique for
working at the dimensionality of the
space like you're saying you started to
give a node consider all them one Edge
motions or two Edge motions look at the
volume of the space that you fill out
and in that way get some notion of
dimensionality and so in this particular
case the answer is about
2.6 and so do you do you imagine you
know I don't even know if this is the
right language in the approach you're
taking but if we think about the Big
Bang yep does it start with a Noe I mean
like what okay so so you
can this is why I was starting to
explain about about different places in
Ral space and so on
there is
uh in in standard relativity we're
talking about different reference frames
different ways to slice what counts as
space what counts as time and so on yes
same story in Ral space so you can it's
the same kind of thing there is a view
of the universe in which it starts with
one node um and that view of the
universe may be a useful view of the
universe for a mind of a particular kind
right it's it's not the only possible
view of the universe that's a possible
that is one reference frame essentially
one Ral reference frame that is the
coordinatization of the universe in that
particular uh in that particular way of
of sort of foliating Ral space that
particular way of of picking reference
frames and so so that's a a reasonable I
think it's a reasonable way to start
talking about things it's not the only
possible way just like in relativity you
know you could you could pick a
different coordinate system and so on
and you would have a different kind of
narrative description of what's going on
even though in an underlying sense it's
the same stuff going on so it's it's a
bit slippery that way now it seems again
I have to admit I'm fairly naive on the
questions I'm asking so if you want to
even correct my questions I'm perfectly
fine with that but it would seem from
the picture that you showed us the
animation that you showed us that the
notion of expanding space
seems fairly
visible and intuitive is is that a
reasonable way of of of articulating in
some gross continuous geometry sense
what we're seeing happening I think so I
think so I mean I I've been wondering
about that sort of the expansion of
space and and how to think about that
and it it certainly Echoes for me you
know Einstein famously you know had
written down his equations and said oh
my gosh these equations imply that the
Universe expands I better add this you
know cosmological term as a correction
to prevent that happening but actually
the universe does expand and you know I
have to say in in in what in what we've
got the the obvious conclusion is the
universe expands because there are more
nodes getting made but there's a more
bizarre possible thing that's going on
which is that that as time goes on
you're generating more and more nodes
and the universe is in a sense getting
finer and finer the our length scale is
fixed but the universe is getting finer
and finer and in fact one of the more
bizarre possibilities when you ask is
the universe discrete or continuous for
example one of the more bizarre
possibilities which we can't yet exclude
is that if you say okay I'm going to
measure I'm going to measure the
elementary length and I'm going to take
a certain amount of time to measure the
elementary length it could be that by
the time you've done that measurement
the universe has subdivided itself to
the point where that measurement no
longer makes sense so that that's so we
don't I I don't think we fully
understand yet what the you know the
notion of the expansion of space and so
on so just to be a little bit more
technical one of the things we've been
very interested in you know in standard
relativity and cosmology and so on
there's you know the Robertson Walker
Freeman Robertson Walker whatever more
names have been added to that since I
since I first started studying lra L
Matra deserves a place in that list I
know he has a good history right but um
anyway so so the the um uh any case that
that's kind of a an aggregate
description of the universe which just
says the universe is roughly this big
and we're not going to we're going to
assume that everything about the
universe is otherwise
homogeneous we would really like to
extend that to include Dimension as a
dynamical parameter in addition to
curvature uh size of the universe we
want to include Dimension and I think we
will understand a lot more about how
this works when we have that kind of
aggregate Dimension changing equation
for the aggregate evolution of the
universe so I'm I'm but presumably your
your your dimension changing quality
settles down pretty quickly otherwise
it's hard to imagine how we get stars
and galaxies at least in our little
corner of this picture right yes yeah
well I mean okay so one of the things
that I am suspecting right now is that
the universe is only three-dimensional
for observers like
us and that and I don't yet know what
attribute you know observers like us
have all kinds of weird attributes you
know we assume that we're you know we're
persistent in time we assume that we are
in a sense localized in space we assume
things about Free Will for example we
assume all kinds of stuff which seems so
obvious to us that we don't even even
identified as an assumption but it is my
guess that some aspect of the way that
we exist as observers causes us to parse
the universe is threedimensional
I I I I think I understand what you're
saying but of course we have all these
very precise experimental results in
terms of you know how the gravitational
field falls off with distance and you
know and these are all consistent with
you know a three-dimensional space but
you would want me to interpret those as
something which an observer like me
would necessarily measure because of my
own constitutional makeup yeah because
you're measuring you know and what are
those measurements those measurements
assume things like okay let me let me
start taking apart those measurements
okay you're right you've got material
objects distinct objects you think you
can put those objects at arbitrary
positions from each other that is an
assumption about free will it's know
there's a whole raft of assumptions that
are being made and you know the
experiment you're doing is a highly
worthwhile experiment to do but it's an
experiment with all kinds of stuff
that's been put into it and you know so
in terms of what we expect for the
universe the
you know we expect that there will be
Dimension fluctuations that is that you
know in aggregate the universe we don't
know why it's three but the universe
will appear to observers like us to be
three-dimensional but we would expect
that there will be fluctuations places
left over from the early Universe where
the universe was about 3.01 dimensional
let's say and gradually kind of calmed
down to being threedimensional we don't
know why it's three as I say but so a
big question is how long do the
dimension fluctuations last and we're
starting to do simulations to try and
figure that out the obvious thing from a
practical physics point of view is did
they last until the cosmic microwave
background was formed and could we
detect them in aspects of the cosmic
microwave background of course we don't
know the answer to that yet but it's
certainly and and we don't even know
what would a dimension fluctuation look
like in the cosmic microwave background
I mean the the most extreme thing that
would be yeah this is a good physics
question right it's it's this is where
you know there's sort of an underlying
model but there's a whole you know big
tower of actual physics that has to be
done to connect it to experimental
observations and I you know one of the
things that's cautionary tale again from
history you know if if the bending of
light around the Sun from generality had
been measured in 1616 in 1916 as as it
was originally sort of might have been
Einstein had the wrong results at that
point and it was only later before then
so you know 1914 I I guess probably
right when the teams went out to measure
the prediction of 1911 or something that
he had the wrong
equations they done the measurement in
fact those astronomers they got arrested
as they went into Russia right that's
that's why they had their equipment you
know confiscated but you're right had
they done the measurement Einstein would
have been in the uncomfortable position
of crying wolf in 19 a little bit later
because his first prediction would have
been false right but but so it's always
you know the going from an underlying
Theory to a measurable prediction is
always a challenge and you know one of
the things that that is sort of a
bizarre possibility is you know the
phenomenon of gravitational lensing
where you know you have a massive thing
and you've got you know lightning bent
on either side and you can see you know
you can in you know you get these two
different images of the same galaxy from
different sides of the gravitational
lens now the possibility is if there was
a fractional dimensional gravitational
lens what might happen is we don't know
know if this happens but it would be
cool if it did that the image of the
Galaxy is shattered so to speak into
lots of little sort of uh fractal pieces
and that if we could get the right
transform we just say to you know our
Space Telescope friends take this image
of the sky apply this transform to it
and you'll reconstruct those pixels and
you'll get images of galaxies that would
be that's kind of the the fantasy
version of um of of what you know how
you would detect a dimension fluctuation
and you know it'll it'll be more
difficult than that right but um that's
the type of thing that that we like to
be able to figure out now you know one
of the questions that comes up in all of
this is okay are there lots of
parameters are there lots of knobs and
switches and so on in these models for
our models there's just one which is the
elementary length what is that what is
we have two atoms of space and they have
a relation between them what is the
translation between that distance
defined by that relation and the thing
we measure with meter rules and so on I
mean it sounds very it sounds very
string theoretic in that way I mean I
mean the one parameter that we have of
course is the you can frame it in many
ways the string tension the string
length or the square root of alpha Prime
however you want to frame it but it
really is this one parameter that you
that you put into the to the story and
for your particular case I gather you
just leave it as a as a as a free
parameter well we we we've tried to
estimated okay so I don't know we have a
very hokey estimate is that how you got
your 10 to the 400 that you mentioned
early on because that felt to me like I
would have said more like 10 to the 200
if I was thinking about plank lengths
and plank volumes the observable
universe yeah so our elementary length
is certainly significantly smaller than
the plank length right so it's you know
more like 10 Theus 90 mters rather than
10 minus 34 Metter but why where where
in the world do you even get that I
notion that it's
roughly the roughly what happens is in
our models there's a factor that occurs
which is the number of essentially
parallel threads of history that exist
in the universe and that number is
pretty big you know maybe it's 10 to0 or
something and essentially that number is
you end up dividing the plank plank you
know units by that kind of number and so
for example one of the Mysteries in in
plank units is why the plank energy is
so big you know the plank energy is the
energy of a lightning bolt or something
which seems very non you know Elementary
I like to think of it as the mass of a
dust Moe but yes I'm sure they're
similar in some ways right um but uh but
so the um you know in our models the
elementary energy is actually very small
and um it's you know it this question of
how big is the elementary length the the
elementary length the elementary time
the elementary energy they're all
related by standard plank units um so
there there's really only one parameter
now you know that parameter it's a
question of are we going to be in luck
in having that parameter be something
that can be measured in our lifetime so
to speak you know when people were
talking about molecules it might have
been that theoretically atoms and
molecules exist but you know it might
not have been the case that there was a
phenomenon like brownan motion that
allowed people to say yes we can
actually see the effect under microscope
of those individual molecules by the way
Brownian motion was discovered I think
in the 1830s long before its
interpretation as revealing the fact
that it was showing individual molecules
was banging into things sure right and
so so the real question is right now for
example can we detect an analog of
brownan motion in space right know what
what is the sign of brownan motion of
space that will be a the sort of the
analog of discreetness of space and I
have a guess which actually is a very
new guess so it's a uh it's still very
fresh from um um and it's it leads me to
a rather bizarre aphorism which is um
back in the in the 1800s when people
were studying heat nobody knew what heat
was and so people invented this idea of
caloric fluid sure which was you know
heat must be this
fluid yeah yeah right that that would be
that would flow from this this place to
that okay so now we have a phenomenon
you know in in and gravity which is
things like dark matter we have this you
know something that causes gravity
but isn't matter that we can see see
what it is so to speak and so my my
aphorism is you know dark matter is the
caloric of our time and what I mean by
that is people uh say what could dark
matter be well what is matter matter is
made of particles let's go look for
particles that make up this dark matter
just like back in the 1800s people said
what could heat be it must be a fluid
let's go study the properties of this
fluid my guess my current guess and this
is a this very new guess so this is like
a this is the first time I've mentioned
this guess anywhere other than um uh you
know sort of to myself so to speak is um
uh I my current my guess not yet worked
out is that dark matter is the kind of
space-time analog of heat and what do I
mean by that I mean that the structure
of space just like heat is really the
microscopic motion of molecules that in
a sense this thing that produces gravity
but is not does not have the the
characteristics of of of standard matter
is a feature of the structure of space
and in particular when you look at for
example that simulation of black holes
yeah what you could see in the
background there was the knitting
together of the structure of space that
was a bunch of space-time heat the the
space wouldn't exist were it not for the
fact that the atoms of space are all
interacting in these ways and so on that
is what makes space the question is is
there a is is there a an effective
temperature so to speak to that uh you
know is there is there a sort of an
activity level and so on to that and I
think you know this is the question what
are the the effective equations for the
the you know for the structure of that
kind of SpaceTime heat so this is a this
is you're hearing this for the this is a
a very uncooked even though I'm it's
uncooked idea it's an interesting idea I
mean obviously one thing I would stress
to the audience is that there are
indirect signatures that the Dark Matter
plays by the rules of matter just that
it doesn't reflect light or emit light
but I agree we've been searching for
Dark Matter particles for a long time
and we haven't actually been able to
find one that we
can our hands plays by the rules of
matter what you're saying is that its
gravitational effects yes are you know
it has gravitational effects agree I
mean and it has inertia and things like
that and and the way that it exerts or
doesn't exert pressure seems to comport
with our understanding of how ordinary
matter exerts or does not exert pressure
for instance so it's a little bit more
than than just that but but yes I can't
sit here and nobody can say what the
dark matter is but how would you
distinguish dark matter and dark energy
then is dark energy also a a feature of
the structure of space probably I mean
you know again this is these are what we
have is a is a kind of a you know we
have a paradigmatically different way of
thinking about space and knowing what
the consequences of that are is not
trivial um and uh you know I think that
one of the things that given for example
that we had a paradigmatically way
different way of thinking about matter
namely that's made of molecules then one
had ideas like that heat could be
microscopic feature of the of motion of
molecules and so on and so similarly now
that we have a different paradigmatic
idea about the structure of space we get
to ask all these questions and and for
instance and you know the questions that
I suppose are the most pressing as far
as I'm concerned are you know how do we
actually know how do we know that we
know what we're talking about you know
how do we get sort of for example sort
of bizarre completely unexpected
phenomena that we go out and look for
and they're actually there and that
that's you know that that's what that's
when you feel really good about theories
is when I mean to me what what's made me
feel really good about this theory is
that everything just seems to line up it
seems to fall into place it's like I
didn't understand how this worked and
now I do actually one thing we should
talk about is quantum mechanics because
yeah I'd love to get to there but before
we do just GNA press you on that point a
little bit so you showed us an animation
a little while ago starting with you
know a very simple structure like a node
and presumably behind the scenes there
was some rule for updating it take this
node and replace it by two nodes that
are connected in some way and so forth
so do you have a very specific rule for
updating a graph which is the rule that
gives rise to you know features like
general relativity on some aggregate
scale no and that's the that's the whole
point in a sense this is what I wondered
about it's like okay we're looking for
the rule and then one day we might say
gosh we got the rule and we hold it up
and we say this is the rule for our
universe and then the next question is
well why did we get this Rule and not
some other Rule and that really confused
me for quite a long time until I
understood this idea of the ruad which
is the idea that all possible rules are
being used and that we are merely seeing
a slice of that right but I'm saying we
beings we computationally bounded beings
whose processing is so slow compared to
speed is there a rule that we beings are
somehow focused up on from the language
that you're using yeah I mean there'll
be my guess is there's a class of such
rules so for example let's do the
analogy in fluid dynamics yeah the
equations of fluid dynamics work for
water as well as for air even though the
structure of water molecules and and air
molecules is completely different and um
that that's it'll it's the same thing
here there there are we we already know
this I mean there are many different
underlying rules that inevitably for
observers like us have these
characteristics
so now if you ask you know depending on
what kind of question you ask if you're
asking questions about air and water
there are certain detailed questions you
might ask which will distinguish
molecular structure of those two
materials and so similarly here there's
there's something where presumably as we
become more precise about what kind of
Observer we are we will home in on
saying oh it's this rule that we're
attributing the behavior of the universe
to rather than that one but that's you
know I I think what we've what we've
observed is that there are uh you know
there are at least wide classes of rules
that have this characteristic just like
there are statistical mechanics of of
leading to sort of the kind of behavior
that we that we expect to see so to
speak so for example the rule for that
uh picture of the of the emerging black
holes is not the same rule as I used for
that other picture um slightly different
rule but it's a simp it's they're both
incredibly simple rules um and uh you
know the one for the black hole merger
could have been that same rule but then
we would have had to just it as you
correctly observe setting up the initial
conditions for that is not trivial as it
isn't trivial for the Einstein equations
either and it's just you know the
technical difficulty of doing that was
made easier by choosing a particular
rule to to look at rather than rather
than that other rule but again not to
get too far in the weeds are there
particular rules that say give you
Einstein's equations plus say a higher
order derivative expansion where you
maybe have curvature squared or
curvature to the fourth terms where
other set of rules don't do that I mean
is it is is it that level of precision
between eventually yeah eventually you
will get that just as if you look at
fluid flow and you look at for example
Hypersonic flow eventually you see down
to the the molecules and then it matters
what the molecules are like but we can't
distinguish you give you know at the
level of general relativity we can't
distinguish when we're looking at the
higher order Corrections and that um uh
you know by the way the the the the
downer about the higher order
Corrections is the scale that determines
the importance is the elementary length
yes so when we're looking at or the
elementary energy or whatever else so if
we're looking at something that's 100
orders of magnitude bigger than the
elementary length those effects are
pretty small we have a something of a
hope that in CRI iCal black holes black
holes you know where where the the the
the effective sort of I hate to call it
I momentum because it's it's all it's
all such a fake in black holes the
spinning of black holes but you probably
have a better way to explain this but
but the um uh you know the parameter
that determines essentially the rotation
rate of black holes yes um the uh you
know at the critical uh you know at the
J equals m critical black hole Point uh
what happened in our models which is
pretty cute is the um uh essentially a
piece of the universe is hanging by a
causal thread to other parts of the
universe so if you were to increase
above that you would essentially break
off a piece of the Universe um and so
what what happens right at that point is
that the the sort of the piece of the
universe that might break off is
attached by only a small number of
causal edges and so there's the
possibility that there will be sort of
the effect discreetness will show up in
that case in for example uh sort of
lumpiness and the gravitational
radiation emitted by black holes in that
state things like this um because one is
sort of it's like having a gravitational
microscope where you've you've pulled
things apart right to the point where
you're kind of seeing down to the
underlying structure of space but again
that these are these are all you know
the the question of of when and and and
when it comes to effects like that yes
they absolutely depend on the spefic
spefic rule that you're using yeah but
when you're looking at the the overall
black hole you know the merger of two
big black holes it doesn't make any
difference just as it doesn't make
difference in the case of flow Dynamics
right um so let's turn then having
beaten away Einstein's equations in
general relativity for a while here if
we turn to Quantum
Mechanics you know quantum mechanics is
of
course in many ways a sloppy or messy
subject compared to the pristine beauty
of the general theory of relativity it
certainly took a lot of hands over many
years to put together what ultimately
we're going to be celebrating I guess
100th anniversary in 2025 2026 you know
Schrodinger's equation Heisenberg's
Matrix mechanics wherever you want to
date it but there's a lot in quantum
mechanics today that many of us well I
should say some of us are not
particularly comfortable with we have
the issues of the measurement problem in
quantum mechanics we have the question
of the interpretation of quantum
mechanics
so are are so when when we talk about
quantum mechanics obviously I'm I'm so
deeply interested to hear your approach
but also maybe at the outset you can
tell us will it give us any insight into
the questions that are still furring the
Brows of quantum mechanicians who think
about the foundations of quantum
mechanics worldwide yeah I think so I
mean you know I feel more comfortable
with quantum mechanics I almost think
that I understand quantum quum mechanics
my friend dick fan who' worked on
quantum mechanics his whole life was
very fond of saying nobody understands
quantum mechanics yeah and uh I think I
am I am getting closer to the point
where I can say I actually understand
quantum mechanics so let me let me
explain what what I think I understand I
mean the so you know we talked about you
know what's the universe made of It's
Made of This this giant Network and uh
this network is getting updated and the
little rewrites are happening one of the
things that you can ask is there's a
rule that says how to do these rewrites
the question is is there a unique way
that these rewrites can happen given a
particular state of the universe and the
answer is no there are many possible
orderings many possible different you
can say I'm going to do this update now
and then I'm going to do this update I'm
going to do that update first and so on
there are many different orderings for
those updatings yes and each of those
different orderings def finds a
different microscopic history to the
universe so in a sense what you have is
you can have a state of the universe you
can have two different possibilities for
how you update it they lead to two
different branches of History somewhat
less obviously they can also be
something where you have two different
states of the universe and when you
rewrite them they end up being in the
same state so you can have this
branching merging structure that you get
and we call these things multi-way
graphs and actually it's turned out that
after we sort of discovered that they're
relevant for physics we've been finding
multi- graphs everywhere and in fact the
the very fact that they seem to describe
some aspects of physics we've been able
to export ideas from physics to a whole
bunch of other fields like meta
mathematics like distributed computing
maybe like biology all kinds of areas so
it's been really interesting to see that
this structure of so many things can H
many things can happen you have
branching emerging give it a very simple
example you play a game like Tic-tac-toe
and you start with a board in a
particular State now you can make one
move or you can make another move and
you can build up this graph this game
graph of all the possible moves that you
can make in Tic-tac-toe and eventually
you know somebody wins somebody loses
but there's this there's this graph and
and sometimes there can be different
moves you make which end up with the
same state of the board even though the
moves were different so it's kind of
this this picture of many branches of
time
that that are happening in the universe
and so then the the question the idea of
quantum mechanics ends up being uh kind
of you're you're you're looking at those
many branches of history and when you
ask a question like well okay so let's
we can we can go in different directions
in quantum mechanics but one question is
what does the Observer of quantum
mechanics what does the Observer do well
the thing you have to realize is the
Observer is embedded in the system so
the Observer The Observer mind is also
branching and merging so quantum
mechanics becomes this bizarre story of
what does a branching and merging mind
believe is happening in a branching and
merging universe and this is where this
idea that we are persistent in time
becomes critical because if if we were
just flowing through all those
branchings and mergings we wouldn't have
a view that we are we wouldn't have this
idea that we have a definite experience
through time but as soon as we assert
ourselves we're having a definite
experience in time we have to kind of
conflate many of these branches of
history and the fact that it is
consistent to do that is a non-trivial
thing you have to show is the case and
the extent to which we see the effects
of there being many branches is
essentially the essence of seeing that
there are quantum effects that's kind of
a a very rough picture I mean I can't
help but jump in as I suspect many who
are watching this would think as well
and and again disabuse me it feels like
Everett it feels like the many worlds of
of quantum mechanics is it just that or
is it something different I don't think
so I think the big thing that those guys
didn't have was merging and I think
merging is really important no no you
can definitely have merging I mean if
you do you know double slit experiments
and you're superposing the the distinct
trajectories I I I think merging is
definitely part of that story too but no
I think the the well I don't know this
this I'm always really bad about you
know okay so my my way of talking about
other people's theories tends to be this
I either really do the history and try
and understand in great detail what
actually happened or I think I have
nothing to say and this is a case where
I really have not done the history so I
I don't really know sure okay but but my
impression is that the kind of the
popular version of many worlds tends to
be kind of our Consciousness could flow
on one of these possible branches and it
is sort of arbitrary which branch we're
on and that's kind of why we see things
probabilistically that's kind of not the
picture in um again it may not be
fruitful to go down this but I think
many edans would say that our
Consciousness itself divides and flows
along distinct
trajectories and in some sense the
probabilities which is a very subtle
question emerge because somehow there's
a greater measure a greater weight
placed on our Consciousness observing
one outcome versus another this a great
deal of controversy in how you define
that measure and you know how how to
really operationally make sense of
probabilities in a universe where
everything happens but yes I think that
would be closer to the spirit of an Ever
Edan yeah but so so I think maybe the
difference here uh is that we're talking
about sort of a you know the Observer as
an extended object in what we call
branchial space The Observer spans the
the the individual mind spans many
different branches of history and so
it's not that uh and and the individual
mind which believes that it has a single
threat of experience spans many branches
of history and is is having to make you
know is having to enforce consistency
conditions to say yes it's really true
that there's just one threat of
experience and it's not it's non-trivial
to establish all those consistency
conditions and make sure that they work
out so to speak um how do you do that I
mean how do you impose those consistency
is that just from a rule from the
outside where you say I need to
impos interesting question okay so this
is um uh we don't know all of this in
fact I'm just a thing that I'm just
writing right now is about what I call
Observer Theory which is an attempt to
have sort of an idealized version of
what an observer does just as things
like touring machines are idealized
versions of What computers do right and
the fundamental thing that observers do
is the equivalence things you know
there's all the complexity of the world
and the Observer is taking some sort of
digest of all that complexity in the
world and stuffing it into a finite mind
that's basically what you look at all
kinds of different observers and it's
it's it's non-trivial so for example in
the case of gases you can say an
observer could be a piston that's
measuring the pressure in the gas and
there are lots of different particular
molecular impacts that could happen but
to the piston all it cares about is the
aggregate of all those impacts and how
the Piston is going to be pushed and
it's a matter of physics that the Piston
has a you know there's a it's a much
more rigid object and so even though
every time a molecule hits it it deforms
a bit there kind of so so you can kind
of but but the the big idea of of
observers is they equivalence things and
it's a little bit confusing because in
quantum mechanics the the big oh I
measured that that bit that qbit or
whatever it's very much more like a it's
the're different kinds of measurement
they're really I think about two kinds
one is things that aggregate stuff and
the other is things like weighing
balances where it's either heavier on
one side or heavier on the other side
and a lot of What's Done in kind of the
quantum information style of quantum
mechanics is more like weighing balances
then it is like the kind of the
aggregate thing what what people do when
they extract chemistry out of quantum
mechanics and say yes we really have a
water molecule that really has this
shape even though quantum mechanics is
talking about lots of different shapes
that's more of the aggregation kind kind
of measurement yeah this this question
of of what um uh kind of okay what is
the Dynamics of measurement um in our
models there certainly is an underlying
Dynamics to measurement the cost of
measurement so to speak we don't really
know how that works yet in fact I'm
literally just the the section right up
on my computer is called the cost of
observation so it's it's um uh the the
um um uh but what we can roughly see is
this there are um let's say you're
trying to make a quantum computer and
you're trying to use the fact that there
are many threads of History that's kind
of what the the big idea of a quantum
computer is you get to sort of run lots
of computations in parallel yes the the
the thing that's difficult with the
quantum computer is reading out the
answer and getting and getting it to fit
in that single thread of experience that
we humans have yes now normally in
quantum mechanics we just say it's a
measurement and it's just sort of a you
know an instantaneous thing we don't
talk about how it works it's just a
mathematical construct in our models we
do get to actually talk about how do
these equivalences get established we
don't have a great model for that yet we
can say sort of how many Elementary
operations have to happen to make these
equivalences occur we can kind of try
and count those and so for example if we
do start counting those it's not doesn't
look good with kind of the formal
success of quantum Computing it seems
like what you you gain in those many
threads of History you lose in knitting
together the threads of History so that
we as humans can conclude that a
definite thing happen so that that's a
but but kind of this this idea you know
can we can we look inside the
measurement process the answer is a bit
but I'm not happy with how far we've got
on that presumably you can say with with
certainty or correct me if I'm wrong
that you do not have anything like
collapse of the wave function that is
not the way
yeah gosh it's so hard to say because
because you know
the when our observers
aggregate sort of different parts of
History I I don't know how to I I don't
know how to relate that necessarily do
you have unar do you have Global
unitarity yes yes then then it's pretty
clear yeah so I I suspect that you know
the the old idea of collapse of the way
probably are not right going to be going
to be singled out in follow right but so
by the way just to give another piece of
what what's going on so we have this
multi-way graph of all these different
parts of history and one of the things
you can do is say let's look at what
state things got to at a particular time
let's make a particular sort of cut
through this multi-way graph and then we
ask well what's you make that cut what's
the kind of spatial Direction of that
cut we know time is going down let's say
what's across we call that branchial
space the space of quantum
branches we say it again what is Branch
Hill space one more time it's the it's
the it's you make this multi-ray graph
so imagine you're playing tic tac toe
you've got all these different possible
possible moves you can make yeah now you
say at a particular time let's just
slice across all those possibilities and
we've got a bunch of those little ends
this is the move that got made now what
is the coordinatization of branchial
space what we tend to do is to say what
is the common ancestry of those so we've
got two little uh you know States here
we say states that were had a common
ancestor one step back we say those are
connected by an edge and a branchial
graph and then we look at that large
scale branchial graph and that gives us
a space just like we're constructing
physical space out of this hyper graph
we construct this branchial space yeah
and so then the question is what's the
interpretation of branchial space and
okay our in in certain approximations
our guess is that branchial the position
in branchial space is quantum phase so
in other words what what in standard
quantum mechanics one of the things that
you know one sets up in the mathematics
you literally mean the phase of a wave
function I mean the phase of a wave
function phase of a Quantum amplitude so
that in other words that that what you
know standard quantum mechanics you know
complex numbers are a big thing and you
know there's this idea that we don't
describe things in terms of
probabilities we describe in terms of
quantum amplitudes Quantum amplitudes
are complex numbers my guess is that the
packaging of sort of magnitude of the of
the of of the quantum amplitude and
phase of the quantum amplitude into a
single complex number is the same
mistake that manovski made packaging
space and time into a single SpaceTime
object wow so my guess is that that the
the magnitude is associated with the
counting of paths and the multi-way
graph and the phase is associated with
the position and branchial space that
you end up so now here here where it
gets really wild so now the question is
how do you think about
gd6 in these essentially in the
multi-way graph you're thinking about
kind of shortest pods and you're
thinking about how do the shortest pods
get formed and what deflects the
shortest pods so what and again I'm
elighting a bunch of sort of technical
detail not all of which I would say
we're we're I consider we've completely
nailed down but the qualitative picture
is the presence of energy momentum
deflects these paths in this multi-way
graph or effectively in branchial space
and so what we're saying is that that
energy momentum is sort of moving around
where we end up in branchial space so in
other words energy momentum is is
changing our Quantum phase and so that
you know what what and in in quantum
mechanics the path integral is precisely
saying that the presence of
relativistically invariant you know
energy momentum the action is what
changes the quantum phase and so what
we're saying is that which I find very
amazing is that what in physical space
gravity is the effect of energy momentum
on deflecting jd6 in physical space in
the in branchial space the energy
momentum deflects also deflects jd6 but
it deflects effectively gd6 which assoc
associated with with position in
branchial space so in other words what
what in physical space is gravity
deflecting things in in branchial space
is the path integral associated with the
way that energy momentum changes Quantum
phase are all is is it just a technical
detail I mean the action is not quite
energy right indeed so is that is that
is that that's a technical detail I mean
you can you can you know it it seems to
work out correctly I mean it's it's this
you know get the right sign you get the
right SN you get the right sign between
yes kinetic and potential and yes I
think so I mean the you know I will say
that
that the you know let me let me rank the
kind kind of ways in which these
derivations have been done okay
physicists have a way of doing
derivations which mathematicians say are
hopelessly unrig okay and and for
example the derivation of uh you know
the gas laws or something from molecular
dynamics that is hopelessly
mathematically unrig um it it it I think
can be made more rigorous by thinking
about computational ir reducibility and
so on but it's it's um in the
traditional way of doing it
it's so the the thing the derivations
that we have are I would say on the
slightly more risque end of physicist
derivations okay and we are working hard
to fill those in with things that are
more mathematician you know style
derivations but that particular thing I
that particular thing is not an issue
because the lran density is what uh why
is that that's because I I'd have to
think about this I haven't thought about
this for a while but but that that
particular thing is not an issue where
so let me turn to maybe a more
conceptual issue that I'm unclear on
where would something like the Bourne
rule come from yeah good question you
know just again for the audience that
you know Max Bourne famously 1926 gave
us the what we believe is the right
interpretation of a Quantum wave
function in terms of what it means for
our observations you take the norm
squared of the wave function or the
amplitude as Steve was saying and and
from that you get the probability
getting this or that result but that
sort of comes from the outside you know
it's not in the basic equations that
they the Dynamics of the system so how
does it show up or doesn't show we have
arguments right we have Arguments for it
I do not think they're mathematically
adequate and actually we're just that's
something just one person who's been
working on this has just been working on
that and seems to have made some
progress in that that area being able to
sort of rigorously derive the born rule
I mean you can we can argue for for it
but I would say that that you know we
should be able to just outright derive
it and we haven't been able to do that
yet let me give an indication of
something like the double slit
experiment a typical Quantum experiment
of roughly how one thinks about that in
these models because it's a little weird
so you know what happens you've got this
Photon it can go through either one slit
or the other one of the Mysteries is
that it can have interference where
destructive interference where you know
you'd say well the photo must have gone
through this thre or that St how can it
be the case that at some particular
place on the screen behind there are
just no photons arriving yeah okay so in
our models what seems to happen is that
these two photons wind up they you know
they go through these slits and they
wind up at someplace in physical space
they also wind up at some place in
branchial space and both photons go
through slits and they wind up in a
particular place in physical space
particular place in branchial space and
what seems to happen is the following
butor why two photons I don't mean to
get but I mean I would love you to
explain this with one Photon okay okay
we could say one one Photon that
that let's um uh you know this this
question of of okay we could say one
Photon and it's you know it's
its amplitude to use the traditional way
of thinking about it winds up partly in
one place in physical space partly in
one place in bral space okay so this
question of what qualitatively is
destructive
interference um I think the picture is
this the Observer is an extended but
localized sort of thing in branchial
space so it is it is observing a piece
of branchial space that's that's
extended but it's
finite but now what ends up happening I
think is that these two sort of
possibilities for the photon wind up at
two different ends of branch space and
so an observer who is a bounded observer
in branchial space just says I don't
know what happened to the that the
photon because I can't I can't construct
a reality in which I I see both pieces
so to speak so and that's could of where
did the photon go well it got lost in
branchial space and I mean that's a very
qualitative way to put it but can you
give me some feel for where I get the
interference fringes in the double slit
from from that descript yeah yeah I mean
okay so so you have to dig much deeper
into kind of this mapping between
Quantum phase and position and branchial
space and as I say uh I mean this is
another one of these things where the
mathematics we have a kind of a hokey
derivation of this which I'm not
satisfied with uh in which one does get
interference fringes but I'm not
convinced by it Ian it's a it's it's
really it's this question of um uh the
the understanding of what branchial
space is and how it works is complicated
it's a different kind of space than
people have seen before kind of
understanding how it relates to the
Hilbert space that one sees in quantum
mechanics is not you know those pieces
are not put together right so you know I
can give you know it is interesting to
see in our models what I find one of the
interesting things is that there are
phenomena in physics where we can give
kind of logical arguments for why they
are that way but we've not been able to
mechanistic Arguments for why they are
that way so for example another one is
time dilation and relativity so here's
here's a here's a way to think about
that in our models so you know the it's
it's for other people's benefit I mean
it it's more or less the you know things
that are going faster time seems to run
slower for them so in our models what is
you know the running of time is this
computational process so a thing stays
in one place and it computes its next
state next state next state now let's
say the thing is moving in order to move
it has to reconstruct itself in
different places in space that
reconstruction process costs
computational effort there are
computations needed to do that
reconstruction of the thing at different
places in space so what happens is
you're using up computation your
computation budget repositioning
yourself reconstructing yourself at a
different place in space so you have
less comput budget left over so to speak
to update yourself in time and that's
the sort of in our models that's the
mechanistic explanation of time dilation
which is to me I mean you know it's we
can derive time dilation easily by sort
of logical argument so to speak you get
like the right the right factor I you
get gamma gamma one over oneus V squ
over absolutely you're putting in but so
you must put in the speed of light right
I mean that certainly is not something
that your model gives you from the
that's just ratio but there is some
ratio that naturally is the speed of the
object to the speed of light yes yes and
the reason that happens okay is is when
you in in space there's this big network
but the thing that really matters in
space time is the causal graph that says
this update happened here how is it
related to some other update that
happens so some updates are Tim likee
related in the sense that the next
update can't happened until the previous
one has already happened some updates
can be space likee separated in the
sense that they you know they could
happen simultaneously and so what what's
happening is in this causal graph
effectively all the causal edges are in
some sense going at the speed of light
and these causal edges are by definition
kind of lightlike edges and so what
you're what you're looking at is then
then the derivation is actually rather
straightforward I see it's just like a
geometrical Factor then at that point
between how you slice the uh yes yes
that's right
um if you don't can we go back to
Quantum Mechanics for because there was
a question there do you have any means
by which you take the classical limit of
I mean because you know the yeah if I
understood correctly the starting point
for getting to a Quantum description was
this fact that you could have these
these different branches from applying
your rules saying in different orders
yep I don't see how you sort of
continuously get rid of that which is
normally how we think of getting to the
classical limit you know we have this
idea of H goes to zero which is a weird
idea since H is actually dimensionful
but we can make sense of it so so how do
you take that limit right so I mean it's
the same thing as in space so the you
know getting to in in space there's this
it's a question of how big is the
Observer relative to the the elementary
length in space yeah and so similarly
here how big is the Observer and
branchial space relative to kind of
these Elementary sort of distances
between branches and so H bar is roughly
I mean qualitatively not some uh is
roughly just as the the speed of light
is associated with know given okay so
given a certain amount of time given one
Elementary time how far did the causal
Edge go in one Elementary time answer it
went the speed of light times the
elementary Time by definition yeah right
and so roughly it's the same kind of
thing that after one Elementary time the
branchial edges are roughly H bar away
from each other in branchial space okay
so so by the way that means that in the
way our model is set up just as there's
a speed of light that governs the
maximum rate of inform which information
can propagate in physical space there is
an analogous quantity the maximum
entanglement speed that is the maximum
speed that information can propagate in
branchial space and that's a new thing
that hasn't hasn't been a story in
quantum mechanics before and and that's
a thing which we are kind of wondering
whether when for example black holes
merge whether there is a sort of the
rate of merging is partly limited by the
speed of light and partly limited by the
maximum entanglement speed and so that's
a we don't know again as I said there's
this one parameter our model so
Elementary length Elementary time or
maximum entanglement speed you can pick
any of these we don't know the maximum
entanglement speed um but you know that
that's another thing that for example
limits the rate at which black holes can
merge the quantum black holes can merge
but does it also again maybe I'm again
interpreting it too much at face value
but if we have a typical case of an
entangled pair are you saying that if I
measure the spin of particle one
on that particle two say would have the
opposite spin in the canonical setup but
somehow there's a propagation speed
which is to do with this entanglement
speed uh yes but it's not in physical
space sure I understand that yeah yeah
right so so there's a I mean this are
these are good questions and you know
this is sort of stuff we're actively
trying to figure out I mean in other
words there's a the um a bunch of these
kind of quantum
constructions um of u u you know CH sh
whatever it is these these um uh you
know sort of quantum correlation
constructions yes the question is how do
those work in our models and can we find
a sort of a physical way in which in
some Quantum many body system or
something we can actually measure
maximum entanglement speed we haven't
figured that out yet and so where would
you put the goal I mean for instance
back in the 80s the goal of a string
theorist like me and many of my
colleagues back then we envision that we
have this approach to physics that
really only has one parameter in it the
string tension the string length and we
envisioned one day being able to
calculate from first principles things
like the mass ratios of the elementary
particles the coupling strengths of how
these particles influence each other and
how the various forces of nature act on
these particles as the years went by we
began to modify our view of what was
likely achievable because even though
the fundamental Theory didn't have any
knobs in it to tune when we began to
look at things like the theory had extra
dimensions and they needed to be
compactified to a smaller scale we began
to see knobs and things that we could
vary enter ing in the theory through the
precise shape and size of the extra
dimensions and various adornments which
those extra dimensional spaces supported
where are you do you envision that this
Earl like computational view to how
reality functions will in principle
predict the mass ratios of the electron
to the muon one day I mean where where's
the ambition and and where do you think
you are in that process yeah I think the
answer is yes it will predict it but it
will predict it for observers like us
and by the way even in traditional
Quantum field Theory yeah the mass of
the electron depends on the observer in
other words the the mass of an electron
depend you know in the rization group
for example Oh you mean in terms of the
energy scale at which you measure it is
that what you mean yes yeah exactly
right I mean there's there's there's you
know you measure the mass of the
electron by kicking the electron a
certain amount and you know that gives
you the mass and the amount you kick it
depends you know gives you a different
mass and there's you know going Quant of
field Theory wants being able to
calculate that running Mass so to speak
so it's it's you know we already know
that there is Observer dependence to
these things so but we probably have a
good enough charactera it probably we
have a good enough characterization of
us as observers that I I think my
expectation is yes these things will be
computable for observers like us and and
I think you know in so let me give you
some predictions about this is meta
predictions about models so you know for
example I think black holes and
particles are going to turn out to be
incredibly closely related and may even
be pretty much the same thing that is
that the um which is kind of uh uh you
know they're both kind of defects in the
structure of SpaceTime and you know
they've come from very different places
in general relativity and in kind of the
ways we've thought about particles but
that's that's one possibility um I think
that uh this question of of you know for
example in in Quantum field Theory and
in the standard model of particle
physics and things we have this local
gaug in variance idea this idea of you
know what what leads to sort of
fundamental forces and so on local gaug
in variance looks it looks fairly clear
how that will emerge in our models the
question is I mean like like like
compact leag groups
naturally yes yes so so just like the
limit of this hyp
is okay so when we think about this
hypergraph we think about you know all
the different nodes in the hypergraph
and we can say these nodes in the hyper
graph are at a certain spatial distance
apart we can attribute some spatial
distance between them but inside that
hypergraph is bundled up all the
internal degrees of freedom as well as
the external as well as kind of the the
the physical space there is also
internal degrees of freedom so what we
have to do more technically we're
dealing with with you know can we
distinguish the base space and the
fibers in a fiber bundle can that's I
was about to ask you yeah okay right so
so the issue is and we've got toy models
of this where we can sort of distinguish
the the aspects of the hypergraph that
are the base space the physical Space
versus the aspects that are fibers the
internal degrees of freedom you actually
really need sheath Theory I would
imagine if you're doing this yes yes and
it it it very I mean one of the things
that's fun with this is I had never
never really understood category Theory
before that you know really working on
this and we need the the most limiting
case of kind of higher category Theory I
mean this rad object is deeply related
to things that growth and deque studied
in the so-called infinity groupoid and
it's it's very it's very lovely that
that these things are I mean one of the
things that to me is is exciting about
the things we're doing is that you know
it's it's one thing would be oh is
string theory right are we right you
know these are two different kind of
polls but I don't think that's the way
it is at all I think that most of the
theories in mathematical physics that
have been welldeveloped have something
useful to say and you know we may have a
machine code that is a thing from which
into which these can all be attached but
it isn't the case that it's like oh that
was the wrong track it's it's like and
and and that same thing is happening
with some of these sort of higher
mathematical Concepts but do you see any
evidence of things like you know su3
cross SU 2 cross U1 I mean I mean this
is the question that that that just like
okay so let me explain in in in our big
graph you can say oh there are these
um uh that there's there's kind of this
uh spatial extent now you can ask what
about for example rotational invariance
yes you're at a particular place in the
graph and you say if I were to rotate
things would I have something that looks
the same well that's a graph theoretical
question because you can wrot you can
you can say you got one graph that's
here and then I've got another graph
that's kind of at an angle and I can ask
can I match up those two graphs can I
make a graph transformation where I'm re
rangling the graph but it's still the
same graph okay it's an automorphism of
the graph and so the the the question
then becomes sort of what just like
we've said oh in the limit this this uh
this graph behaves like a manifold or
something we can ask when we're looking
at these a like things is is the limit
of that something like a Le group
something like a continuous group okay
and so the thing we don't know is just
like we don't can't derive the number
three for the dimensions of space it is
I think conceivable I'm not saying it
will happen this way I think it's
conceivable that for a wide class of
models that there that everything will
be a subgroup of E8 or something that
the that it will necessarily be the case
that the thing we derive as being that
internal Le group degree of Freedom so
to speak has to have certain
characteristics I I don't know that
that's the case but I think the things
we're seeing so far make it not
completely crazy that that would be the
case well make it E8 make it E8 cross8
and then we have definite resonance with
yes yes right yeah well I mean we just
don't know this is this is one of these
things where you're you're kind of you
know there is a there's it's it's um uh
it's a you know the thing that is both
exciting and kind of humbling is you
know the model is right there now we
just have to do the hard work of
figuring out what its consequences are
and if it turns out the consequences are
crazy and don't agree with what we
observe physically then we're out of
luck but I have to say at this point I'm
that's I don't think that's going to
happen because too much has how many
people how many people are working um is
it is it you and a in a small team or
well I mean it's locally we have this
thing we call wolf from Institute which
is a small small group of people but
there's there's a a wider collection of
people who' worked on different
different aspects of this and I think
that the um I mean the I don't know it's
I haven't counted because it's not
really a I mean there's a there's a
small inner group so to speak which is a
modest number of people but there's you
know that and there's a a certain amount
of bridge work that's been done to
whether it's to categorical quantum
mechanics or to other kinds of fields
where people are like well you know
we're really working on categorical
quantum mechanics but we're doing it in
the context of the connections to this
model I see so it's some I mean I think
the uh uh kind of you know the way
physics tends well I don't know physics
I I've been out of physics as a I
haven't been professionally doing
physics in in in 40-some years but it
used to be the case I I I happened to be
lucky enough to work on physics you know
in the late 1970s when it was having
kind of a golden age of the sort of
arrival of quantum field Theory and then
subsequently cosmology which I was quite
involved in and uh uh you know that was
the kind of the the my this my sort of
feeling for the
um uh at that time there was this great
tendency for everybody you know some new
thing would happen and every phum on it
yeah yes right and um I think uh you
know that would be nice if if that if
that um you know more people the thing
about what we're doing is that you know
some of it is very paradigmatically
similar to mathematical physics some of
it really plugs into mathematical
physics but quite a lot of it does not
quite a lot of it is more like
distributed computing you know
mathematical logic uh just you know
computer experimentation things like
this and it is somewhat paradigmatically
different um and and also I would say
that that you know this is what I get
for having spent 40 years building tools
the tools we have are pretty you know
streamlined LED and efficient and
there's a lot of things where it's
pretty easy for me given those tools to
jump pretty far relative to what people
are used to doing in kind of the steps
that they take in doing mathematical
physics and so on so that makes it you
know there's a lot of kind of alien
stuff gets made possible by that and
that I think makes it you know in a
sense I I've been sort of you know as
time goes on that the you know it the
tower that we're building gets a bit
taller and it gets a bit more difficult
to kind of you know when people sort of
get involved we do the summer school and
winter school about this project and you
know that's sort of it's getting
challenging to fit kind of the what we
know so far into a few weeks of lectures
course and that's uh uh you know I think
that that that's kind of but you know to
me you know the more people we can get
involved the better right now I mean one
of the frustrating things is there a lot
of experimental physicists who are like
we've got a telescope we've got a
particle accelerator you know we would
like to look for something unusual and
interesting just tell us what to look
for right and we're still in the
situation where we're like we don't
really know yet hey we we've been in
that position in string theory for quite
some time so you see but this is this is
why we need to make the right bridge to
string theory because we want to make
use of everything you guys have figured
out maybe you'll find what we've figured
out useful I think one of the things
that's been exciting for me about about
this project is that for example I I
said there'll be you know people said
what are you working on I say
fundamental Theory of physics people say
oh that doesn't sound very practical and
I'm like yeah you know it might have
applications in 200 years um and uh the
surprise to me is that I was wrong about
that there are actually applications now
to distributed computing because the
model that we have of the structure of
SpaceTime is basically a model that you
can think of as events happening and so
on and that is and think of that as
being a big distributed computation and
so the ways that we have to think about
SpaceTime now becomes ways to think
about now become ways to think about
distributed computing right we're
starting to think about you know
programming in a certain reference frame
things like this so we're importing by
using the fact that we have a common
formalism we're able to start importing
successes from physics into other areas
so to my surprise there actually seem to
be some pretty near-term applications of
not the so much the physics side of this
but the Bridge that's made to physics
from the kinds of things we're doing
yeah well I can make you a pledge right
now for whatever is worth you correctly
calculate the electron to muon mass
ratio and I will drop everything that
I'm doing and and work that's GNA be a
challenging one give me something you
know I I've that um uh you know the time
when we can see what
um uh the um you know uh it's you know
getting
206 is um is is uh you know I'm I'm not
counting on that being soon I have to
say some things about these models have
just dropped much more easily like the
the idea of what energy is I thought
that was going to be a long I thought
this whole thing was going to be a maybe
we could talk about what happens in the
first 10 Theus 100 seconds of the
universe but we'd never have things to
say about kind of things that are more
obviously connected to sort of current
uh it I think the other thing that's
been a very interesting surprise is this
fact that the the methods we're
developing are practically useful to
people who are doing things like
numerical relativity that's that's a
thing I that's true I didn't I didn't
know that that that is true I mean the
numer yeah yeah yeah that seems to be I
mean I don't know we've been Jonathan
gorard who's one of the people working
on this who's been um has been traveling
around talking to numerical relativity
groups who are starting to use software
that he's produced that is based on our
models so that that's a that's
encouraging um and you know I think I
think that's um um so yes electron muon
Mass ratio I'm not counting on that one
anytime soon right you know I might get
you an E8 I think an E8 would already be
impressive enough well you know because
of the classification of compact League
groups again the small number in some
sense of truly distinct ones that are
out there I don't know if that would
okay as fully as it may grab others but
I can't help but make one comment which
is you noted that in your approach the
Rel there may be a relationship between
black holes and and Elementary particles
that would be interesting I don't know
if you're aware of it but a paper that I
wrote with Andy strominger and Dave
Morrison some years ago we found
something of exactly that sort we found
in string theory that if you have
certain shapes manifolds for the extra
dimensions and you take a particular sub
space within it like a sphere and you
collapse it down to a sufficiently small
size it can look like a black hole for
most of that motion but when you
actually collapse it right down to zero
there's a smoothing of the space in
which that black hole turns into an
elementary particle so there's a yeah so
there's a direct link that we found
through certain kind of deformations of
the extra Dimensions that was a direct
link between black holes and Elementary
particles so again whether that has an
incarnation in anything that that in
your approaches you know it just uh
certainly jumped out to me when you said
that yeah that that's very cool I didn't
know that I mean I think the the um um
it's it's um uh it's funny because you
know I knew the physics of 1980 or so
pretty well yeah and then I've been kind
of in in a uh in you know it's like a
cryic freezing for um where I was only
partly paying attention for a long time
but no I mean that that that type of
result that's interesting and that's you
know that's exactly why one should try
to make a a better bridge between our
models and string theory because one
might be able to see you know how that
really you know fleshes out in uh you
know in our models and then in string
theory see how that really you
know this this extra Dimensions thing is
going to I I don't know we we'll see but
I I think this idea that you're kind of
lifting out of this hypergraph both a
spatial Direction and internal degrees
of freedom I think is you know I don't
know how related that is but I think
that's going to wind up being you know I
mean it's that that has a certain I
don't know there's a certain cutness or
something to the whole um you know to
that whole kind of way of thinking about
things but but I would I that that would
be my my guess for how that will how
that will end up working out and that
that in fact you know again that that
one will you know if if you know I
as I say I I I think the the thing that
to me is really interesting is it's not
like in my view you know there's sort of
a a sense of where mathematical physics
has gone and I just don't think I think
that there's been I mean it's kind of
analgous I suppose to what happened in
the early days of computation where
people had different models of
computation and then touring machines
came along and that was kind of a way of
of anchoring a bunch of different kinds
of ideas and then you could take these
these models that have been often more
difficult to understand and you had kind
of this pretty mechanistic way of
thinking about them and you could build
a whole lot of stuff from it so I'm I'm
kind of that's my that's my qualitative
view about what what I think can happen
and it's well look it's uh it's
wonderfully exciting stuff and I think
as we all know if you're going to shoot
for the stars you've got to be willing
to fail miserably and so you have to be
bold and so you're certainly being bold
and it'd be fascinating to see how how
this develops so I'd love to check in at
some point again with an update on where
things are look I'd also hope today to
speak about but we'll put it off
hopefully for another conversation if
you're willing to do so the whole AI
stuff and and Consciousness and Free
Will and all those wonderful ideas but
um you know when you have an opening in
your schedule in the future it'd be
great to connect again I'd be happy to
talk about that I've got the this week's
fun thought is quantum
llms
there you go okay so that's intriguing
enough all right so so thank you so much
for joining us and we'll we'll talk
again at some point in the not too
distant future yep lovely to lovely to
chat great thank you all right everybody
that wraps up this uh live session which
um if I'm being completely honest and
too much information and partly wrapping
up because I've got to use the
facilities and sitting here any longer
will be definitely dangerous but it's
been a a wild ride in this conversation
with Stephen Wolfram as we expect
expected it to be trying to perhaps find
the underlying computational structure
to all the things that we as physicists
have for the last hundred years been
enamored with statistical mechanics
special relativity general relativity
quantum mechanics Quantum field Theory
and who knows I mean the thought that
there might be some deeper underlying
structure that allows us to understand
where these laws come from and as well
tie it to the fact that we are the obser
obers that are aware of these laws well
it certainly is bold big exciting who
knows if it will pan out but that's the
nature of being at The Cutting Edge so
thanks so much for joining us for this
live conversation please subscribe to
our YouTube channel or subscribe at
worldscience festival.com to be updated
on the various programs that we are
undertaking about a week ago we released
a wonderful conversation on AI some of
you may have seen it if you've not you
should check it out with Yan laon
Sebastian bubic and Tristan Harris where
we really describe the inner workings of
some of the llms that Steve wolin just
made reference to as well as discussed
some of the potential dangers or as some
in the program suggested the
overinflated view of those dangers of AI
going to the future we'll be releasing
shortly I believe our next release will
be a program on cosmology that we had at
our live events in September and please
as well keep your eye on we will shortly
release a really wonderful conversation
on string theory the state of string
theory that we had at that event with
David Gross Ed Whitten Andy Stromer and
myself really trying to give a feel for
where we are you know here we are 2023
these ideas began in 1968 where are we
in the process of trying to
realize the potential of string theory
and so that program will be released in
the not too distant future as well all
right I think that's about it on the
updates again subscribe to our YouTube
channel go to worldscience festival.com
subscribe to our newsletter and we will
be having a of these live conversations
going forward but for now that's it here
from Columbia University my office here
this world Science Festival Live event I
Brian Green thanks for joining
us
[Music]
he